foreign
welcome back it has been a while I
missed you guys I've been uh you guys
know I've been all over the the country
doing uh interviews this last week uh my
guests today I've been very very excited
to have her on she's originally from
Chicago she used to sell copiers she's a
semi-pro volleyball and basketball
player and by the way she's also has one
of the most controversial podcasts on
the entire planet welcome Miss Pearl
here Pearl how you doing I'm good how
are you excited to have you on here
we've been talking on Instagram uh and I
was just excited I I thought I was gonna
have to come out to London I will at
some point come out there because I love
your I love your studio yeah I think
it's awesome it looks like a lot of fun
but um you decide you came out here to
do some you're doing a US trip how's it
been so far it's been good
yeah so that was
ties those girls were wild the girl
directly across from you not the one at
the far end but the one next to her uh
she's a Gwen singer she's one of my good
friends oh
which one she had a deeper voice she has
like an announcer voice you remember no
she had a red dress on no I don't know
yeah I was asking her they were just
telling like they're just saying their
body counts and I was just like this is
crazy isn't it crazy that's not like a
girl was like 200 I'm like 200. What's
that 200. the one in the Middle with the
boobs kind of oh okay yeah damn I gotta
go back and listen to that yeah that's
how I was like oh gosh that's a lot
um so so here's the thing I I went back
and I watched a couple things so
um I don't agree with everything Matt
Walsh says but I do think that he has
the right to ask what is a woman and
when people say yo that's silly it's
offensive for you to ask that question
that's not silly you can ask that
question and the fact that other people
can't answer it that's actually a pretty
big [__] in the armor you go on Vice
okay Vice has you on you have a panel
where you're with a bunch of feminists
and you asked a simple question you said
how are women oppressed now if I did
some research I could probably come up
with some ways that women were oppressed
but that that the one lady who was
sitting to your left um she's a trans
woman with those short hair the blonde
hair I forgot what what she was but what
her name was yeah
yeah Eli she said that's just silly and
that got me angry because I was like
sitting there trying to watch this
open-minded but when she said that's
just silly I'm like no pearl can ask
that question yeah because that's that's
where the discussion breaks down right
if I ask you a legitimate question about
your political Viewpoint and your
response to me is that's just silly or
we're not going to answer that that
means you're too insecure to answer the
question so can you talk about like how
did you end up on that panel in the
first place and then what was your what
was your whole um
experience like that oh
um they messaged me like a week or a
week and a half before it happened and
they just said they're looking for women
um to go on a panel about feminism and I
was like sign me up you know
um and yeah they they flew me out to New
York and it was actually like four hour
it's crazy we we went back and forth for
four hours and it was edited down to 45
minutes yeah and that was like the most
loony group of women I have slash men
all right men
um that I have literally met in my life
like they were so hostile towards me
like the whole thing and the thing is
they didn't even keep in like they were
10 Times Crazier in person than on the
video but but it was honestly it was fun
though I I enjoy making contents and so
I it was all all together it was fun to
make but God damn they're mad it
definitely looked fun you know one thing
I noticed I don't know if you saw
recently but um my buddy Justin Waller
and Lucario they were on a thing on
Jubilee like last week yeah and when
they went on there it was the alphas
versus the betas and they were having
these and they were yelling at each
other a little bit and at the end you
could see there was just almost like
yeah guys let's all go get a beer
together yeah at the end of of your
thing with those ladies there was no
let's go get a beer together no we did
not get a beer together
no they were so angry
um yeah they were really angry yeah
incredible man I recommend everybody go
back and watch it because I remember
watching that and I was like okay this
girl is gonna have I what I what I
expected was like rational points from
both sides no and I didn't get that at
all and I kept like waiting for somebody
to come up with some kind of Statistics
to like back up what they were saying
and then when they told you you were
Silly for asking the question I was like
this is this is like there's no debate
here like you the other people who are
against you are not qualified to have
this discussion there are people
qualified to have a discussion about
feminism there are even if I don't agree
with them they're qualified because
they're educated in it what I was
watching was not that at all that's what
that's the part that I thought was a
little bit you know disappointing well
and the freaking the worst part of that
was when I was talking about playing
sports because that sounds I care a lot
about women's sports like that's
something like that was really important
to me growing up and I feel like it kept
me out of like a lot of I don't know
like the trouble I guess because I was
so busy in sports
um and I think it's really sad to see
like the end of women's sports like to
me like when you let men into women's
sports so it's the end of it yeah like
that like women's sports isn't women's
sports and when I asked when I was
expressing this on the panel they told
me to try they're like because I was
saying
I can't bench what a guy benches I can't
I can't do the same things a guy does
like I'm six foot I'm not I'm top 15
percent of height for men like half a
percent of height for women and the the
Eli dude was like have you tried
confidence I was like what you said it
was so crazy watching that because yeah
that's what you said before so for us in
Texas we had this um boy that
transitioned to become a woman named
macberg and uh she won the state
championship and put some girls in the
hospital on the way there wow and when I
was listening to again that the the
woman to your left she her saying
there's only been a few national
championships that have been won by
trans men in women's sports and I'm like
well 0.02 of the population of trains so
that's the reason why again the problem
is this like that is not an excuse this
idea that just because it's happened a
few times doesn't I have no problem with
somebody being trans what I have a
problem with is when my daughter wants
to do female wrestling in in Texas and
then she's in there and she has to go up
against a man who went oh let's say a
trans person who went through male
puberty well and I just don't think
anyone understands like how hard we work
for those like few moments like we work
so hard like I started playing
volleyball when I was in fifth grade I
started playing basketball maybe like
second or third like I I've been playing
for over 10 years and I can count on one
hand the moments like I've had to go for
a State title or for
um an NCAA like I went to the ncaas
twice in volleyball in volleyball meant
a lot to me you know to go to that and
then I went to State uh one once so you
know I had three moments and like 15 you
know about 15 I don't know 16 roughly
years yeah and it's like so these girls
like and that happened at Riley Gaines
girl she trained for 15 freaking years
maybe even more and her whole entire
career leads up to this one moment
that's supposed to be her moment and you
put a dude in that like now I've never
played against a dude well other than in
like pick up basketball I've done that
but but you know professionally but I
could just imagine like going to all of
that work and and we worked so hard
that's the thing like we get there's no
money at the end of it there's nothing
at the end of it except for like a very
very small percentage so we work so hard
for the the little opportunity that
there is and we all do it because we
love it and they're they're trying to
give that to dudes like I just I just
have an issue with that so you play
division one where no I didn't play
division okay I wish you know no I
played um division three I played
basketball volleyball and I ran track
where was this I'm Elmhurst College is
this in Illinois yeah it's a very small
School in Illinois I played for Ohio
Northern for a year and then I
transferred okay uh so I'm a basketball
Junkie okay describe I've never heard
you talk about this describes Pearl's
basketball game
um I'm very I'm very aggressive in the
pain I was really good rebounder so like
are you usually the tallest person even
in division three or on your team are
you the second tallest person on your
team division three I'm one of the top
in division one like that's the thing I
was actually short
um for the positions I was division for
division one you play the three maybe
the two but you can't play the four no
you can't those girls are six eight
correct yeah yeah so um and same with
volleyball too
um like for my position you kind of had
to be like six two I don't know that
much about uh six player volleyball
right the hardwood fall yeah yeah are
there a lot of different are the heights
all different or the girls all around
the same no the heights are all
different
um I was a middle slash like outside but
those are a bit taller back rows shorter
okay I didn't realize that I had no idea
about that though yeah the little bear
the one in the other color jersey
they're like the shortest one usually so
in when you play college basketball you
play the five yes okay so describe your
game you're a rebounder like what what
kind of I was I was a rebounder I was
really good at boxing out like when I
would box people out for rebounds I
would knock them over sometimes and I
would um I was a really good posting up
um yeah and I actually had a decent
three too okay so Pearl's go-to move
you're playing somebody who's like maybe
even bigger than you what's your go-to
movie when you were in the post back
them up into the basket and just do a
layup like there was my and you shot you
you're a good three-point shooter yeah
you handle the ball not really I
actually want to play basketball with
you yeah I'm so down
um no I wasn't that was my weakness was
I couldn't really dribble yeah so I
could I could do a three like I could
run out and shoot it yeah but other than
that like I wasn't gonna drive really
much
um I was just like a post or slash three
but I had to run out defensively you
were under the basket all the time yeah
I was I was a pretty good Defender
um yeah I was a pretty good defender in
England you said you were playing
Semi-Pro volleyball and semi-pro
basketball yeah well I I played for the
school so I think it's Tech technically
something else I played for the school
of volleyball and basketball I did
Semi-Pro volleyball in England yeah so I
mean are you playing for a team there
like how does that work yeah it's a bit
confusing
um but basically you do your master's
program so you you get your master's
degree and you get like a scholarship
for it and then you play for the school
and then you also play for the semi-pro
team you can actually play pro
basketball in England but I was not that
was like the best team in Europe where I
lived I was not going to make that too
but I was I was a better volleyball
player than basketball okay very yeah
very cool now the the transition because
here's the thing you're doing a show
where you talk about male female
relationships right and I'm curious
first off how did you being an athlete
affect your ability to be in a
relationship and then number two you we
talk about you had you were on with
jeded abilo right yeah Jedediah had this
discussion before so that I did not have
a baby until she was 40. wow okay she so
she did it and she doesn't recommend
other people do that right maybe I think
38 she got married first she had a baby
she's 44 now she has a four year old
she's not in the middle of the standard
deviation we know that right that's
going to be before 28 before 27 someone
in that area she waited till she's 40.
she has a baby now and she says okay I
know I'm out here in the fat tails of
the of the standard deviation it's a
very rare uh what did I forget what the
stats are you probably know about losing
half your eggs at the at the age of 30.
yeah and it almost and it's less than
five percent two percent once you across
the age of 40. so I'm curious uh so she
understood that she was in essence
talking bad about boss women yeah but
she was one at some point because she
was on The View right she waited till
she was 40. yeah it was something she
talks about she's like I know I was
living that life but I wasn't happy
right so I'm curious from your
standpoint being a college athlete and
then having this podcast has this been
difficult for you for your dating life
um yeah I mean I would say just
hey just the sports for sure like it's
tough to like be traveling in and out of
States when you're in college you know
because the the schedule we had was like
really really intense
um but yeah I would say I would say it
makes it tough sometimes because of the
traveling yeah just because of the time
like that's why after this season I was
like I'm done I'm not doing this again
when I play when I ran the track yeah
the girls I used to date were track
athletes yeah was it like that for you
were you usually athletes with the guys
that you would go out with
um yeah do you like male basketball
players is that like a type for you
um
hmm
not really no I mean they're they're
like fine but like basketball players
are a bit like there tend to be like
kind of players okay try to not you know
like they're good looking do you know
what I mean but like it's just kind of
you're kind of asking for trouble there
got it got it yeah
um so from that standpoint uh again I'm
curious because we talked about this
before in your situation you're now a
public figure right on the show Also
let's back up to one other thing I
started this podcast because of some
remnants that happened because of a
breakup I went through a breakup and
this girl started lying saying all this
kind of crazy [__] about me and I was
like I'm never gonna let anybody start a
narrative about me right that's why I
started this two years ago you did you
is it true you started this podcast your
podcast or you started creating content
after getting out of a relationship I
did start the podcast after a
relationship yeah I was kind of watching
red pill content before that but yeah I
did start it like after I got out of a
relationship it was that a catalyst for
you
um
partially I guess yeah actually probably
yeah looking back yeah did you when you
ended this relationship did you feel
like you were trying to get back at
somebody or you wanted to tell your own
story or was it no no it wasn't like
that it was just more like I was sad
okay like I was just really sad like I
like I did end it but I was really sad
so um it was just kind of like a
distraction I guess
was you're not to get too personal if
you don't want to yeah like did the
relationship end because of mistakes
either one of you made or was there any
anything bad like that that happened
um I think I just realized our
backgrounds were just a bit too
different okay like for like a long term
like um because it was just kind of
getting to the point like it if we dated
longer like it's kind of like what's the
next step you know and I was just like I
just think I needed someone with a bit
more similar of like values background
that sort of thing your views since
watching The Red Pill content has now
you you mentioned before you grew up you
look up to your father your father was
yeah very well off grew up in a 10
bedroom house yes yes uh you know with
how many siblings do you have uh it's
kind of a sorry this is a it's going to
be a long one to dance I remember your
oldest is is was adopted or was put off
well first yeah yeah nine um I grew up
with six okay so when I was growing up
in in my house like I was the second of
six they adopted two after I left for
college so two teenagers came into the
house they adopted one teenager when I
was a baby she moved when I was one and
they gave up one kid for adoption so I
was in um
I I
I met him when I was 22. so now I know
like so it's kind of weird because I
grew up with sex but like total it's 10.
got it yeah dude you you had talked
about this in length I've heard you say
this before where they say high value
men would always cheat yeah you would
tell your dad like Hey Dad you're
supposed to happen like that yeah yeah
did your Viewpoint change from there to
when you started watching red pill
content where was the ethos for you to
start creating content like that oh it
used to trigger me when they would say
that oh my gosh that would be so
triggered but when I when I realized
like my parents kind of grew up in a
different time and I realized like what
they're saying is they're more likely to
cheat when they're in that category and
the question more is like as a woman
what are you going to do if they if he
does you know what I mean and I just
think like at the end of the day you
shouldn't break up a family like for
your own feelings
um there's exceptions right but no it
used to trigger me I used to have like a
different opinion on that
um but no my dad my dad's never cheated
No One Believes Me like everyone always
says yes he has but my dad's like one of
the best people I know to be honest like
he's never drank he's like been with one
woman his whole life like I don't know
my dad's my dad's awesome do you think
the possibility or the archetype that
you see from your family is part of the
reason why you make this content because
it'd be one thing I feel like most red
pill content is why we're [__] up and
you have a family uh when I look at my
grandparents so we're together for 75
years yeah when I look at something like
more than 75 years I'm like okay well
there's an example where they didn't
[__] up
do you look at your family like that
like maybe this is an example of what we
could do if men and women would change
their behavior
um
you could say that I wouldn't say that's
like the reason I did Red Pill content I
just found it interesting yeah to be
honest like I was just interested in it
yeah
um I mean there's like I feel like
there's more than one it wasn't like one
reason that I did everything but yeah
what caused things to take off for you
um oh my gosh it was my red everyone
thinks it was the show you know what's
funny it was not the show it was
actually
um uh basically I started like I did
start the show so it was while I had the
show
um and what I would do is I would
explain Concepts that I was like
watching in red pills so I think our
first episode was like guys like do we
actually like that you know this is like
so basic now but back then it was like
kind of new to me so I was like guys do
we actually like toxic men do we
actually like bad boys like what do you
guys think about this yeah and when I
would explain a concept um and I think
in that episode somehow trans stuff or
something came up it was something
um or the maybe it was the pay Gap I
think it was the pay Gap that's what it
was and very which is really off topic
but then I was explaining how the pay
Gap isn't real to this girl in the show
named Jess and after I could see I would
always take the girls where the wheels
were like kind of turning right you red
pilled your friend yes and so then I
brought her back and that was like the
first series that took off and it was
kind of like a system where I would do
the show and then the girls that were
kind of like huh like the wheels were
turning out take them back and then show
them like a red pill content creators
yeah stuff so well I mean I guess Jordan
Peterson isn't like red pill rat but
they use that word for so many different
things yeah yeah the thing with Jordan
Peterson is he he evokes he invokes
evolutionary psychology a lot and that's
why you put him in that category yeah
and also like again we're skipping ahead
you discussed before about
um Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson
talking about an attack on masculinity
right right and you're a big fan of
Jordan Peterson yeah I am do you do you
feel can you describe like how you think
that works because I I feel the same way
uh where there's an attack on just the
concept like I don't think there's such
thing as toxic Maxi linear I think
they're toxic people yeah they can be
masculine or feminine but when an a seal
team is coming to rescue me from another
country I want those [__] to be
masculine as [__] right I don't care
about their toxicness do you uh do you
do you feel like there's an attack yeah
well I actually had like sort of a red
pill moment when I was listening to like
one of Rolo streams and he was talking
about how like the the masculine way of
doing things is always considered wrong
okay and I was and I was thinking about
it and I was like it's the same way
they'll say oh you need to open up
emotionally to men but that's not how
men process emotion yes and so like what
I realized I was like oh my gosh like
the masculine way of doing things is
always wrong and I mean before that I
always knew it I mean in a way because
it's like you have all these girls
saying men are trash men are the problem
like but that's like the basic talking
point like when you really peel it down
I was like that is so interesting
um I think what it is is the when men do
things in a masculine manner it doesn't
feel right okay again when you when you
use the example of the burning building
or storming Normandy then the masculine
way is right it doesn't matter how you
feel about it but when it comes to like
I have this conversation again with when
I talk to some of my female friends or
my girlfriend but we're having a
conversation I'm like you're listening
to the words I'm saying and then you're
looking for an additional meaning what
I'm saying but I mean exactly the words
I'm saying there's nothing additional
it's just the words I'm saying there's
nothing else and they're like but why
are you so mad at me I'm like no you
didn't hear what I just said I'm not mad
at you what's going on is I'm saying
words what the truth is exactly the
words I'm saying but you're like looking
for my hand movement and my eye
inflection yeah we do and there's
nothing going on and it's so hard and
like especially for me with women I work
with and women when I'm on a date before
I've gotten this relationship it was one
of these things where like I need to be
able to trust you the only way I can
trust you is if I say I'm gonna be here
at this time time and you understand
there's no additional meaning it doesn't
mean I'm going to be here at this time
and [__] you I'm mad at you it just
means I'm gonna be here at this time if
you can't just literally listen to the
word that I'm saying and understand the
literal meaning we can't accomplish
things yeah and that's the thing that's
so scary to me which is why we get into
the the 304s go over here right and then
the men you work with are over here
because we're getting off topic here but
one of the things that always bothers me
is
because I'll have feminists on the show
and I have a lot of my female friends in
La usually they're feminists and we'll
have this discussion I'll be like you
want to be taken more seriously in the
workplace let's say specifically science
technology engineering and Mathematics
okay and then when you do so when I ask
you how you picked who you dated you
started quoting astrology
[Laughter]
I supposed to take you seriously right
understand what I'm saying yeah yeah so
again again one of my uh one of my
friends she was uh uh interviewing me
for um a financial Network for
tastytrade
and and while she's interviewing me
Vanetta Logan and she's interviewing me
and she's like this is why women need to
be taken more seriously in this
workplace and then she says I don't sign
a contract when Mercury is in retrograde
and I'm like do you not understand the
problem there it's like you don't
understand regular physics it's okay to
believe in astrology as like a fun thing
yeah it's like watching when I watch the
Hulk Hogan Fight The Ultimate Warrior I
knew it wasn't real they don't really
hate each other right they probably swap
wives and get steroids from the same
person they're not actually hating each
other the problem is when people start
thinking Sagittarius is real Libra is a
real thing but then I'm supposed like
you want me to take you more seriously
how am I supposed to take you more
seriously when I'm asking you to read
the evolution of Desire but you're
quoting the five love languages to me
right you see what I'm saying I'm asking
you to read why beautiful people have
more daughters but you're quoting sperm
Wars to me or you're you're talking
about something you read in 50 Shades of
Gray how do I when I'm when I'm giving
you objective facts and you're quoting
back to me how you feel about something
I don't know how to have a conversation
it's by the way everything I just said
that goes for Holocaust deniers flat
earthers and uh and and just anyone else
who's people who deny the moon landing
like they're not using reality or any
sort of reason to get into their their
Viewpoint so I can't use logic or reason
to get them out of it and that's that's
one of the difficulties I found yeah but
yeah I mean that's the main one is is
like when I hear people say I want to be
taken more seriously in a certain field
and I'm like but you still believe in
nonsense you still buy lottery tickets
yeah the flat earthers are interesting I
was like I kind of wanted to talk to
some of them okay I know what do you
want to know oh I just wanted to know
why they think the Earth is flat like
you ready okay I did four hours a four
hour debate oh gosh okay so what they
believe is what's called empiricism and
basically the world is what I see and
okay anything that is outside of what I
see is probably not true so the idea of
quantum mechanics isn't real okay right
the I the the concept of gravity because
I can't see a graviton it's not real and
so they what they do is they make the
world basically be what it looks like if
you look at the world from a as a six
foot tall person standing in the middle
of a desert it looks flat it looks like
you're on a flat plane but the reality
is the planet that you're on is 24 900
miles around okay and so because it's
that big you can't see the curvature in
it one of the things Buzz Aldrin said
when he landed on the moon is he said I
could actually see the curvature of the
Moon because it was so much smaller than
the earth does that make sense I could
see the Horizon the literal Horizon of
of land Beyond
so what happens is what flat earthers
believe is that like this whole thing
was a conspiracy and you'll notice
there's a lot of uh anti anti-semitic
stuff in here there's a lot of um
Rothschild Illuminati they're protecting
you NASA is part of this Global cabal
conspiracy to hide the truth from you
and whenever you try to produce any kind
of evidence to counter that all the
photos are faked really all of them are
faked uh they use CGI in 1969 no that's
not true do you think any of the photos
were faked no what happens is this do
you know how to use the panoramic view
on your phone yeah okay what happens
when you use the panoramic view what
happens is the AI in your phone starts
taking all the photos the multiple
photos it takes and then it matches them
up together right that is called a
composite on NASA's website because
sometimes you can't have the focal
length work to take the picture of an
object 20 like 8 000 miles across you
have to use a composite of multiple
photos to get a photograph of the earth
do you understand yeah because the photo
is a composite flat earthers didn't say
it's faked faked is not a composite is
not faked zirka what's going on that's
his name right yeah I definitely I
definitely want to go ahead mean yeah
well you got to explain this you're the
flat earth guy so it's the photos aren't
fake now he's just gonna say they're
fake he's not going to provide any
evidence that they're fake he's just
gonna satisfied he's gonna say why is it
that the flatter symbol is the same one
as the United Nations and I'm like no
dude that's not evidence people don't
understand when people say evidence
whenever I have a feeling about
something it's like isn't that a
coincidence a coincidence is not
evidence right they'll say it's evidence
does that make sense I'll give you real
quick when you next time you talk to
zerko these three things they won't be
able to counter them number one when I'm
standing in Buenos Aires when I'm
standing in Sydney and what I'm saying
in Santiago I'm sorry Buenos Aires
Sydney and what I'm standing in
Johannesburg When I Look to the South I
see the Southern Cross when I'm in
Nevada I can't see the Southern Cross
because I'm in this I'm in the northern
hemisphere
when I look in the same direction in
Johannesburg yeah South when I look in
Sydney South and when I look in
um uh or uh what is it Buenos Aires
South I see the same object if the Earth
is flat in those three areas I should be
looking in three different directions
because the Earth is flat but it's not
because I'm looking at the same object
the Southern Cross because the Earth is
round it's unequivocal proof that the
Earth is round that's the end of the
discussion okay the second one is if I
look at the Moon flat earthers believe
that the Moon is 4 000 miles away well
if the moon is four thousand miles away
if you do simple trigonometry if I'm
standing in the tip of the Southern uh
South America and I'm standing in Alaska
I should see a different face of the
moon right because it's only four
thousand miles away but I see the same
face of the Moon all the time because
it's 38 000 miles away because the Earth
isn't flat and the Moon is a sphere or
it's a it's an oblate sphere with OP
oblong spheroid whatever it's called
oblate spheroid so that's the reason why
that's the second unequivocal proof that
the Earth is round and then the third
one is I used to fly for the US Military
and if the Earth was flat a trip to go
from South Africa to uh South America
would take like 20 hours because it
spreads yeah does it make sense but it
doesn't it takes seven hours yeah so
what they're saying is the retort to
that is no it's because you're flying
faster than the speed of sound and I'm
like no I'm in a 747. I can't fly as
faster than the speed of sound and they
just make up this nonsense those three
proofs but here's the number one proof
the absolute unequivocal proof that
would not only landed can I guess can I
guess what is it is it the the time like
the sun is like time changing no no okay
okay Nikita Khrushchev congratulated the
United States for landing on the moon
oh think about it
so he's he's lying that the United
States landed on the moon they were they
were literally willing to go to nuclear
war with us but they're gonna lie that
we went to the Moon like that's that's
the main did they ever land on the moon
no no no no no no other humans landed on
moon from any other countries just the
12 men from the United States there were
six six I don't know much about space
travel yeah I just yeah no we can get it
like
if he wants to go into like the event
yeah come to Vegas
the Van Allen belt nonsense like all
these stuff there's answers for all of
it it's just the thing is like the
Holocaust denial and Flat Earth the
reason why I go after these two
specifically is because they can't exist
if you take any time to look at the
other point of view if you look for
reasons why the Earth is round you
understand why the Earth isn't flat and
if you look at reasons why there were
six million Jews that died during the
Holocaust you can't come to any other
conclusion that six million Jews died in
the Holocaust because there were nine
million Jews before the war and there
were three million Jews after the war
they didn't just vanish they didn't
aliens didn't take them off they'd end
up in the United States they weren't in
prison camps in Russia they just
non-existed anymore Nick you gotta come
on too but but here's my favorite part
here's my favorite one again during the
during the Nuremberg trials when they
asked the Nazis none of them denied that
there was a holocaust
none of them there was no Holocaust
deniers until the 1980s yeah just not
because it was 40 years and so many of
those people
you know I'm not going to explain his
point of view because I've had enough
but yeah Nick you gotta come on no for
sure yeah yeah no no problem
that's the thing like the problem is
again I'm not making a judgment about
any of the other stuff right is there a
One World Government that's not my point
the point is when you believe in these
things you're doing so because you will
not you're not allowing yourself to even
look at the other point of view are you
a deep State believer
um listen I work for the federal
government like no they're morons like
okay the real answer is so boring Pearl
people hate the real answer you know you
don't think there's like a globalist
agenda depopulation no here's the
problem like if you really understood
how stupid people get at the federal
level you would never believe this [__]
like it's so I did see it a bit in
Corporate America that's not the that's
not the federal yeah but like I I flew
for the military for seven years and
like we're flying airplanes that were
built in 1957. yeah in order for us to
get the paperwork we had to fill out to
get a new pencil you're telling me
there's some globalist conspiracy no are
there a few rich people who have like
really bad agendas [__] yes of course
yeah but this idea that it's just like
like two things can be true right
Hillary Clinton would have been [__]
horrible president and she doesn't eat
babies those two like do you think do
you think she was killed do you think
you believe her body list or whatever
she's killing everybody
um
a lot of people have died around I don't
actually I don't actually have an
opinion
his thing
I just think I think conspiracy theories
are kind of fun yeah they are fun but
they're but like the problem is they're
fun but then what is feminism like you
called you said feminism was a hate
group right you remember said that yeah
but like do you understand how it's like
we want them to understand the truth but
then it's okay to believe in Flat Earth
do you see how that's kind of like
hypocritical yeah you understand what
I'm saying we're using empirical data to
show yeah when a woman cheats in a
marriage 83 of the time she picks a new
partner right that's a really good piece
of information but when I explain to a
flat earther that's a retro reflector in
the Sea of Tranquility and we go shine a
[__] laser in a beam come back in 1.1
seconds or 2.2 seconds which irrevocably
I'm sorry proves that there is a retro
reflector up there and we landed on the
moon that also and that evidence is
thrown out but the evidence that women
cheat is not thrown out it's like you
believe in the evidence when it supports
your cause but not when it doesn't I'm
for the evidence in all cases so that's
the thing if red pill is a derivative of
evolutionary psychology then let's
believe this the science then but then
we can also believe in the science it
doesn't mean that there can't be
additional signs but the point is like
it's like we want to believe the truth
when it comes to male female Dynamics
but we don't want to believe the truth
when it comes to [__] what happened
during World War II that's stupid I just
think that's hypocritical this is my
point okay sorry we're getting off topic
here
um I do want Hillary Clinton's body list
though yes no uh I don't think that she
intentionally is asking people to kill
other people do I believe that there's
somebody in their organization that may
have like may have done something like
this possibly there's a lot of people
you're right but like do I think that so
for instance let's just say the people
who believe that um the the wretch the
election was stolen if you think that
Joe Biden is sitting in a room just like
pointing out different places where the
election is stolen is someone in the
organization maybe doing it possibly but
it's not like like you understand what
Barack Obama wasn't holding a gun to
kill Osama Bin Laden it was seals who
were doing it there are people in the
organization who put that or put that
whole thing together it's not Barack
Obama who is literally doing it so I do
I I don't know I really don't okay
my gut tells me it's like it's easier to
believe that it is true but it's not
true I don't know I mean he doesn't have
to I was just curious dude it's really
hard to be a political conservative
person and then have all these [__]
conspiracy theories that like you have
to deal with like it's crazy like no
dude it's I don't know I just want to
get two down so I'm sure I'm gonna end
up on some stream getting yelled at by
bunch people but like it's just like I
said before
Hillary Clinton can be a terrible
president and not eat babies at the same
time both things can be true I didn't
even hear the eating baby yeah they said
she drinks adrenochrome from babies and
all this I've heard that but about
Hollywood
I mean I don't know it's not like my dad
when I tell him these conspiracy
theories that's what he says
so before because I'm gonna get so much
hate for all the stuff I just said okay
before I go any further let me say this
let's say all of it's true let's say
there really are lizard people who live
under Antarctica do they think there's
lizard people have you not heard this
yeah let's say let's say George Soros
and Hillary Clinton a drink adrenochrome
let's say all that stuff is true yeah
that's the reason why you live on your
mom's basement
is that the reason yeah because the
Illuminati
no you live in your mom's basement
because you're a [__] loser that the
one of the things I love that Andrew
Tate said is that he said there's a
matrix and I just learned how to
manipulate the Matrix for me
whether it doesn't matter who president
United States is if you think he's a
[__] Android or a Democrat or if he's
Bernie or whoever
is that the excuse why you're fat is
that the excuse why you're broke is that
the excuse I don't care who the
president is I'm still gonna be rich and
in shape I'm not going to make excuses
so if you want to believe in conspiracy
theories that's fine but when you do it
in order to hey either try to get a
bunch of views or two because you're
trying to make copes for your own
failures in life that's where I see it
to be in a problem you see what I'm
saying yeah like there are real
conspiracies that nobody talks about how
about the Tuskegee experiments where
they're letting men have syphilis
African-American men have syphilis in
Alabama for years they had they had
antibiotics back in the 1930s and they
were just letting these men die of
syphilis for years how about the Iran
Contra affair where they were like
shipping crack cocaine into California
we don't talk about real conspiracies oh
wow but we talk about the ones MK Ultra
we know that the CIA was giving people
like mind-altering drugs they're real
conspiracies out there but we're still
stuck on Bush playing 911 like what the
[__] are we doing yeah one of my
favorite things was Julian Assange with
the whole Wikileaks thing he comes out
and he he said dude I've just given you
millions of [__] emails I give you
all this evidence and you guys are still
stuck on Bush playing 911. I have no
evidence to support that whatsoever
there's so many other conspiracies that
are actually out there that you guys
don't want to worry about because they
don't involve lizard people you know
what I'm saying yeah that's the issue
I'm sorry like
yeah okay we're going way too far down
this what I do want to talk about is
this one of the things that you said
that was an inflection point for you
like you said before you're trying to
Red Pill one of your friends yeah which
I think is awesome yeah
you said that there was getting attacked
by whales oh the
real Attack yes yes so there's multiple
like apparently there was one main one
and then there was multiple others well
no I mean you know I do go in kind of
hard on the fat chick yes I know I know
they get mad at me for this the original
whale this is how the whales started
okay I I was doing Street interviews
okay and I was doing Street interviews
with these two ladies now one was in
shape one was
a whale yes okay and so what happened
was she
um I was talking about safety like she
was doing that thing women say oh I
can't walk home alone at night and it's
like blah blah blah and so I was just
like well why don't you just not walk
home alone at night you're not entitled
to safety you know I mean it'd be nice
if we have it but it's not like you know
men can't walk home alone at night
either and then this really triggered
her so she just knocks the mic out of my
hand and she's trying to attack me
luckily I had a guy with me she's like
which was interesting cause he was
talking about the men attack and I'm
like you're attacking me right now and
she's like I'll have you you slag I'll
have you and I'm going like this because
my friend was like holding her back you
know yes and I didn't know what a slag
was so if you don't know that is a ho ho
yeah yes it's a UK version of a yes and
I I didn't know what that meant at the
time but I knew I was being insulted
Mike I I was like yes I'm being insulted
right now and so then I was just like
well you're a whale and that was how it
started so then I just started like
blanketly calling like fat chicks and I
don't mean the nice fat chicks I mean
the fat chicks that throw their blubber
in their face and so then I did some
tick tocks going after the fat chicks
they started harassing my family one
kept calling my mother one got my mom's
phone number kept calling her well yeah
and they just it's a very um so the
second attack was a virtual attack
really
um but yeah I've only been physically
attacked once okay well so in that in
that situation you mentioned that that
video got taken down so they didn't care
about the part about this woman
attacking you they cared about the part
about you calling her a whale I guess I
lost my first Tick Tock account I almost
had a million followers and that video
was on there that was the one that got
me taken down you still have it
somewhere do you have it posted anywhere
it's on YouTube it's on um I think they
actually re-clipped it recently and just
blurred the lady out because on YouTube
it got taken down because of a privacy
complaint Tick Tock it got banned but
it's on Jessie Praises Channel if you
guys look him up that's good she talked
into a microphone right what she talked
into the microphone so yeah that's legal
consent yeah I don't know that's what I
said too um and she actually
she was pretty drunk so I kept trying to
tell her either get in the shot or get
out of it because she kept coming in and
out and I was just like like lady either
get in or get out like I don't and so I
actually told her to get out of like she
kept coming in the shot I was like I
don't care you're not that you're not
hot enough for that yes like I can go
get a hotter chick to interview like
it's not yeah so I couldn't believe they
took it down but yeah that's how the
whales started what was their reaction
afterwards
yeah I mean it went super viral yeah
um until they deleted the video off my
channel but it went pretty Violet got
like I don't remember how many views it
got but it got my friend monetized on
YouTube so wow yeah so he was happy uh
did that have an effect on your audience
that went to YouTube
uh not really it was like the same
audience okay because it was like asking
about I can't remember what exactly we
did the video on but it was it was
something with like red pill type
content so who did you mentioned before
the people who trigger get triggered the
most by your content are who you just
think it's like you mentioned before you
thought it was girls who had a high body
count or girls who
um
feminists yeah I would just say General
feminist probably the one I mean I do
use the word whales a lot I kind of do
it to be funny but I I think it's kind
of funny so so yeah I would say whales
and feminists when when it comes to the
stuff you talk about on your show do you
think it's uh so like when I talk about
these Concepts I try to do it in a
descriptive you mentioned before like I
do a lot of research on the stuff that I
talk yeah I try to describe what I think
the world is like but I don't try to
prescribe meaning I tell my friends I'm
like if you want to be a girl on only
fans who have sex with a guy and only
fans multiple guys you can do that
because you live in the United States
and you're free to do that but there's
going to be consequences and these
consequences are the pool of men that
you're gonna have to select from are
narrower and narrower and narrower and
when we start with men who are over six
feet tall six-pack abs well you know not
obese and make over a hundred thousand
dollars a year we're only talking about
point three eight percent of men in the
United States so you start with that
number and it starts to shrink as you as
he realizes this woman is having sex on
only fans do you understand what I'm
saying when I just in the nicest
possible way try to express the
consequences to them there's no Jesus
you're sinning you're immoral I don't
call him a hoe none of that I just
explain the consequences yeah and I do
it mathematically I get called a [__]
misogynist and I'm like how is this
possible like and do your some of these
people are like my friends I'm like how
the [__] are you calling me a misogynist
for pointing out numbers to you
yeah I mean I mean I just think it's
when they don't really have an argument
to be I mean I don't really think it
matters how you say it to them I think
they'll be offended either way that's
one of the things that I thought was
interesting is like I start off the art
just as an experiment I'll start off the
argument by literally saying you can do
whatever you want yeah you can do
whatever you want right you can be happy
there's a lot of money you can make
doing only fans I'm sure you can now
doing whatever you want here's the
possible consequences if you came to me
and said hey Michael you know you play
pick up basketball for 25 years your
knees might be [__] up I'm not gonna
go [__] you dude I can't believe you
said that to me piece of [__] yeah like
no I was like hey you know this probably
you're probably right well I just don't
like I feel like older women lie to the
younger generation of women okay and I
just think I I what I hate is I hate
lying to girls and I just think it's
like dishonest to say you can just do
whatever you want and have no
consequence like it really pisses me off
I have three little sisters you know so
it's like you're gonna say you can just
do whatever you want there's no
consequences even though especially when
it's women over like a certain age where
they know deep down there are
consequences for those kind of things I
mean didn't that study just come out
that said like 90 or 80 of only fans
um workers like are content creators
it's yeah it's like 80 I think it was 80
to 90 of um guys or it was either it was
either 80 to 90 of only fans content
creators said they were rejected because
of it or 80 to 90 percent of like guys
said they would reject someone because I
don't remember probably the second one
yeah it was but because I'll tell you
right now those girls who make that
money on only fans do have boyfriends
they are getting in relationships yeah
one of two things happens either the guy
they're with has some other kind of
proclivity meaning like maybe he's
bisexual and he's fine with the content
creation or he's in content creation
also yeah or what's most likely is that
they have a man who like they lowered
their standards and picked a guy who was
very stable yeah and then eventually
they're going to leave him yeah that's
most again not all the time right I
definitely know some like one of the
things is when I made these comments I
had friends of mine that were married
and they both do only fans together and
I'm like I'm not talking about you you
guys are doing only fans together like
there's some girls that go in there they
don't even pose nude I'm not talking
girls who are literally doing hardcore
porn to make a buck and then I'm I'm
just mentioning that there might be some
consequences for this and I'm just
getting [__] hounded my girlfriend is
actually more Draconian about this than
me she's like I'll never have an old
defense any only fans I won't do
anything like that and she made it but
she seems awesome I saw her on whatever
yeah she seems so cool yeah she uh so
she makes a video and she in the in the
video she says I I found my dream man
and he's proof for me that because I
don't have an only fans I know that for
me to get a girl guy like this I need to
not have an only fans right and the hate
they're literally calling her a
misogynist for saying this she can have
that opinion that's what was so crazy to
me yeah well and I just I just really
don't like lying to younger women and I
think a lot of older women give younger
women bad advice because they're bitter
about the position that they're in yes
and it's like I I would rather like tell
the next generation of women like that
that this stuff will have consequences
especially because I just have three
little sisters yeah I just don't like I
think what I think what the issue is is
there's very little short-term
consequence and when you're in your
feelings you don't think about that yeah
here's the thing I think people are the
way they are not because of a lack of
morality but it's a lack of consequences
and let's talk about it on both sides
yeah Jordan Belfort
yeah Quaaludes prostitutes 15 months or
like 27 months in a federal prison all
this stuff is he more famous or less
famous after he commits the crime oh
more famous that man built a career you
saw the dude um from fire Festival
what's his name um fat or I've heard of
him yeah he goes on CNN the other day
he's doing fire Festival part two
the Tinder swindler is starting a
coaching program
horrible yeah yeah okay
O.J Simpson is about to get hired
because I talked to him about it he's
about to get hired to do a uh fantasy
football podcast okay
Oliver North who is part of the Iran
Contra affair was a correspondent for
Fox News
and when uh uh what's his name um Logan
Paul he goes in that forest and there's
that dead body up there and he brought
he violates terms of service for
for uh YouTube he becomes more famous
afterwards remember he's canceled and he
does the fight with KSI now he's more
famous my point is no one pays for
anything short term
Pearl and so when when you have these
women and they're looking at it from a
situation where they see the glitz and
glamor of one thing but they don't see
any sort of long-term consequences I
think that's what the issue is it's not
there's no consequences there's no
there's no short-term right I have a
question do you think women lie about
how much they make on only fans
um yeah I think a lot of them do but
some of them I could verify well because
I was there's a couple girls on the show
I was on them whatever where I started
like looking at it at like their likes
or whatever like one girl said she made
70k a month and I was just looking it up
and I'm like you don't even have like
subscriptions on here yeah
um yeah and I was and I was looking up
the number of women on only fans that
made that amount of money it was like
point zero one percent I was like maybe
she is I don't know but you're right A
lot of them are lying because if they're
making 300K a month doesn't it make
their decision seem like it makes more
sense yeah because even some men are
going to hear 300K a month and be like
ah okay I get it yeah and here's another
funny thing so I talked to them and they
may be coping they may be not telling
the truth but I talked to a lot of them
and when they do make 100K a month or
200k a month and they buy a new house in
a nice car they tell me that there's
this point to where their parents are
like okay I can see you're making good
money from this and they're like okay
with it now I don't know if they're
telling the truth I'm just gonna just
gonna take them at their word but there
is a point where is it 500 000 a month
at what point is it now then okay to do
this and then what are you giving up in
the future right Playing devil's
advocate 500 000 a month is a lot of
money yeah there's a certain amount of
happiness you can't buy with that yeah
you understand what I'm saying I'm like
that's a lot of money yeah I know
several I know at least 10 girls who
make 300K a month wow and I talked to
them about this whole situation and it's
really interesting like from everything
from like their entire lifestyle is now
a tax write-off everything they do is a
tax write-off which is crazy yeah um and
then and then when you ask them to come
on your show whatever fresh and fit they
immediately say yes they'll fly out so
Stephanie well will they tell them to
come on Stephanie Stephanie palomares oh
dude I'll tell uh yeah UK will come uh
hit up um uh you know Vitale you know
the the guy Vitali who used to make the
prank videos on you YouTube
uh his girlfriend's Delia Rose I bet she
lives in Manchester I bet she'll come on
your show she's like yeah yeah I don't
know her but so so
um I forgot what my original point was
but um the the you know the concept of
like they're not being that many
consequences anymore I agree with you on
this but I think that's the reason why
there's a change no I agree I mean I was
thinking about it I'm like really we're
bailed out of every bad decision we make
like it's like if we sleep around
there's like birth control and there's
abortion right which I'm very like
pro-life yeah
um and even if we get pregnant like we
can put them on child support we can
give it up for adoption like which maybe
hypocritical my parents did that but
um and and then even if we're bad with
our money like there's a million
government benefits yeah and it's
actually crazy in the UK I'm doing this
like divorce documentary yeah um right
now so you're you're given a divorce
attorney what no something like when in
cases of abuse the state pays foreign
yeah I think it was like five years ago
or maybe seven roughly
um the UK made it like that you get free
counsel if um if you are a cute if you
accuse a guy of abuse and so basically
like with one phone call like if I'm
dating someone and I just decide you
know I'm really just not feeling it
anymore I can go to the police get him
arrested and he can't see his kids I can
get him uh their version of a
restraining order there with one phone
call he came out of the house he lives
and put him on child support until the
trial which often times is like six
months to a year and a half and then by
the time we get to trial he hasn't seen
his kids in a year and a half and so now
they give her primary custody because
the kids haven't been in their life even
and there's no consequence for this and
they also get a free lawyer and he has
to pay for his yeah that makes it rough
um that when you consider a 70 uh I'm
sorry 50 divorce rate I don't know what
it is in the UK it's roughly the same
it's like 53 something like that yeah
and then the concept of the majority of
those marriages are dissolved by women
or the initiation of divorces is
initiated by women yeah like so for
instance here would be the difference in
like me and like some other people in
the in the space I will say if 70 or 75
of divorces are initiated by women then
it's a smart thing for a man to get a
prenup but I'm saying that not because
of women or hoes I'm saying that because
the stats show that the likelihood is
she's going to initiate the divorce and
so she she should not be incentivized
financially to initiate divorce with you
this is something me and Brandon Carter
talk about all the time it's like what
well I don't I don't think marriage is
marriage anymore okay like it's not it
can't be marriage if you can get out for
any reason yeah like if you read
marriage vows it's like for better for
worse for richer for poorer and sick
descendant Health like all that so it's
like is it really marriage if the
average marriage is like eight years
yeah like that that's not marriage it's
something else it's basically just like
a contract for a long-term relationship
essentially uh I think it's sad like I
don't say that in like but it's
interesting because when I first got
into the red pill space I was so I was
kind of triggered I was like why are
these guys so anti-marriage like my
parents are good if they have these kids
they built this business together they
both came from nothing like it seemed
like a really good idea but then
I've been doing this divorce documentary
and I'm just like I can't think of a
reason why I'd sign up for that as a guy
yeah
um I don't know as much about the laws
here but in the UK it's like crazy yeah
um I that's one other thing that Rolo
said which which was he prescribed he
encouraged marriage in his own life but
he doesn't he doesn't like the idea of
marriage uh the current way that it's
done he he gets I hate how much they run
him up the flagpole for that yeah I it
actually really bothers me because they
never I don't know that I think the fan
is on but they never actually listen to
what he's saying yeah like because he's
saying that the contract is bad like
that's what he's against he likes the
institution of marriage of course yeah
but like today's marriage isn't marriage
but it actually it really irritates me
because they always misquote what he
says yeah but it's like they're not
listening yeah I'm used to that they're
getting misquoted for what he says yeah
um so the thing is with the marriage
deal
um and I've heard this too you know when
if you talk to Justin Waller sneak or
whatever they're gonna say I wouldn't
have a legal marriage right or marriage
including the state but I would have I
would have a marriage outside like a
religious marriage but it doesn't even
matter like that's a sad thing half the
guys I interview I guess it's funny it's
a divorce documentary but but
um half of them aren't even married it's
just with the kids like what I can't
think of a wedding they're losing their
kids and not married which in which in
case in the United States I know you
have a much harder time keeping custody
so if you for those of you don't
understand if a man and a woman have
kids together and they're not married
the likelihood of the woman taking the
children full custody is actually much
higher yeah if they're married yeah well
in the like I had guys that I
interviewed where they avoided like the
legal marriage just but the same thing
happened to them there put on child
support
um they were accused of abuse and it's
really sad to see like it is so sad when
I enter like I've interviewed so many
guys where like I I I wouldn't be
surprised if they committed suicide so
that's another thing we're going to talk
about is that men being zeroed out after
the age of 40 in their 40s and 50s when
there's their financial destitution and
then their their wives have left them
they're nine times as likely to commit
suicide side yeah no I I see it like
I've interviewed these guys like there's
one guy the state
um literally like he was warning like
his his wife or girlfriend or whatever
basically got into this like feminist
group and that's like the other thing
because they'll be like oh just find a
good girl but even a good girl can get
like the wrong friends or in the wrong
group and that's what happened to a lot
of these guys and so they would like
they would get into
um so like she would get into this like
feminist group and they would start like
talking or whatever and the the crazy
thing that happened was
he was warning the state saying like
this like this is getting out of hand
like these these people are like the
group is crazy yeah and one of the girls
in his the friend group killed the son
out of spite like these are the people
like I literally have talked to and um
the state then took the other guy's
child away so like not only did they not
listen to him when he warned them about
like that group they took through his
kid away and now he's in like foster
care yeah it's becoming one of these
things where you can imagine in those
court systems they're like well we don't
know what's going on so let's just go
ahead and give it to the mother well
they're using heuristics to just make
the the trials quicker and faster well
and I didn't realize that in family
court it's not about evidence it's on a
balance of probabilities I'm sure you
probably know this but also in civil
court you know you don't yeah in a
criminal court it's going to be uh
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt yeah in a
civil case which this would be a civil
case you have a preponderance of
evidence yeah so that's that's that you
have a proponent so that's a different
thing you can be held 40 liable or 60
liberals two people get in a car
accident so this would probably be a
civil defense no the way it works though
is there's like six or seven types of
abuse okay and so like I don't know
exactly what the number is but let's
just say it's like on a scale of one to
ten and if you get a score of let's just
say a six or seven you're considered
abusive and the problem is they're
expanding the definition of abuse so
they're saying like coercive control is
abusive I don't want to like go out if
you don't want me to go out clubbing
with my friends if
um Financial abuse so you you didn't let
me spend five thousand dollars on the
credit card I can even say that you you
graped me because I didn't actually want
to have sex when we were married like
like it's crazy and if a guy gets like a
six out of ten and and the women's
shelters are in on it because basically
they'll go to the women's shelters all
these feminists are there telling the
girls exactly what to say based on like
your background so they have like
um a story to give the girls for each
like this is what you say for a Nigerian
Guy this is what you say for a Polish
guy like it's it's wow yeah it's crazy I
I want to I couldn't find someone crazy
enough to do this with me but I've
literally wanted to like find people
that could like try to go inside of the
system to like show this because I've
heard this from multiple guys yeah that
is crazy the thing is like let's just
say somebody's listening to this right
now and they're like well you know most
women wouldn't do this and I and I
understand where that argument would
come from my point is you would be
incentive if you wanted to keep your
kids and you're a woman and you
understood that all I have to do is in
the short term play fast and hard with
the rules and I get to keep my kids what
would you be willing to say like for
anyone who's out there who just thinks
that this never happens what would you
be willing to say to take your kids away
from your partner would you be willing
to say that he did these things to you
and then if you were aware that there
was a system and was being coached
through that system in order to do these
things what would you be willing to do
well and I and I think of like male and
this is kind of a weird thought process
I have but I think of like male evil and
female evil and like if you take male
evil to its extreme I think of like
aggression right like murder like
whatever like Mao Zedong and pole pot
out of Hitler yeah yeah yeah yeah and
when I think of female evil toots
extreme I think of spite okay and I
think like women like we're at our worst
when we're in like a relationship where
we feel like we were wrong whether we
were we weren't we're at our worst and
right now like the government is giving
us the power to do the absolute like to
do awful things where we're like at our
worst that's like you know how many more
people how many more guys would like
kill if the government incentivized them
to do that yeah like when they're
they're most angry so let's talk about
this I think it's it's I wasn't planning
on this subject but this is you'll
probably find this interesting so I have
some friends of mine that are worth a
couple hundred million dollars we'll
just use Bulgarian as an example damn he
lives a couple blocks from here right so
Dan uh has girls signed an NDA when he
comes when they come into his house and
he has cameras in every single room
specifically for the reasons that you
talked about and we had this discussion
before and he said I've never had a
problem because beforehand we establish
we film everything and like it's one of
these things where I tell guys to film
everything you guys you notice whenever
there's a fight on fresh and fit
immediately everyone takes their phone
because they're afraid that the girl is
by the way there's a group of girls
behind uh Chris that their specific job
like icy their specific job is to get
the girls out of there without the men
touching those girls does that make
sense because that's what that's the
world that we live in now so they make
sure and then they film everything so
that make sure that there's no
um you've seen the situations before
where somebody's accused of a crime and
then the video comes out and it's
completely the opposite of what they say
um they do that and I think it's really
smart I and I encourage you guys to do
this all the time never type anything in
a chat that's going to incriminate you
because let's just say a girl and a guy
go back and forward on IG like they're
dming each other and then the girl goes
and deletes all of her messages and it
just looks like the guy has just been
stalking her screenshots it and sends it
to her friends so I don't write
incriminating stuff on there okay I
recommend people to do that and then
whenever there's any kind of altercation
I say film everything yeah film all of
it well I first heard when I first heard
like the the ring stuff like make sure
you film everything as a girl I was like
oh my gosh like why would you do that
like I mean maybe not right in the
bedroom but maybe in the bedroom I don't
know like there's some there's some
moral no I mean after listening to these
stories I'm like yeah film everything
fellas so so yeah so Bulgarian says one
time he was raped by a woman what I mean
by that is like he was asleep he was
passed out
um he does an interview where he talks
about this and he wakes up and this girl
is like writing him and he has he's like
I don't have a condom on like this girl
is just like having sex with me or
whatever and he doesn't remember
anything any of it he was like [__] up
beforehand he goes back and he watches
it on video and he can see that he was
raped like he can literally see it and
he tells the girl afterwards like
they're eating they're like if you
weren't hot I would have called the cops
in you isn't it really crazy but like he
but he filmed the whole thing to protect
himself wow again this is a public story
it's not some private story he told me
if you guys go watch the fresh and fit
interview yeah into detail about this
but um yeah just run one of these really
interesting things where I personally
think a solution because there's both
sides of this right there's the the
believe all women side that is saying uh
all these things are being underreported
right and then there's the men in the
red pill side or they're like they're
like rape is just being used constantly
as a tool in order to use against men
and my whole my answer to this whole
thing is let's just document everything
let's just find out what the actual
truth is yeah you see what I'm saying
that's what I would propose as a
solution yeah and whoever objects to
that that's probably your culprit right
you see what I'm saying yeah that's what
I would say Let's find let's try to find
a middle ground do you want to ask you
something before we went by
um uh dealing with abortion and you said
you're pro-life in the cases of rape or
the cases of uh would you still be in in
I'm 100 pro-life and also like something
like preeclampsia like where a woman may
die giving birth you still feel the same
way
um I don't know I've heard they kind of
mislead you with those things like this
is just what I've heard I don't I'm not
like it you know an abortion expert like
I know all the special cases but I've
heard there's very few cases where that
actually happens okay like it's like a
very much extreme yeah
um I I I don't know that that I don't
really have an opinion on okay
interesting cool good
um let's see here one thing I thought
that was really interesting uh 20 not 20
years ago maybe 15 16 years ago I used
to briefly for two summers I worked with
mystery from oh okay oh my gosh I read
that book yeah yeah for sure and I took
Neil Strauss out for his birthday I'm
friends with Neil okay I haven't talked
to him in a long time but we were
friends and then Owen Cook from RSD I'm
curious you said you went on a pickup
boot camp
yes can you give me details This was oh
gosh this was this is when I was before
I even left for England because a lot of
people don't know before the show I I
was reacting to Red Pill content for
like a year okay and I was doing like 10
reactions a day so I watched like a ton
of [__] yeah
um
but yes um I was reacting to pick up and
I was thinking I worked in sales so
there was this guy
um I'm not even gonna people don't
really like him or whatever there's beef
but but he he had to live in Brazil
keep me out of it get me out of it um
her name's Bennett and she's not in it I
don't I don't like to be in the middle
okay um he already put me in the middle
so I don't get oh you know oh sorry okay
but but he was um
he he had uh like like approach things
or like pick up videos and it reminded
me of sales a lot it is a lot yeah so I
worked in sales for two years like
selling copiers and I was like wow this
reminds me of like a sales call and I
thought it was so interesting and so
basically this guy said I could come to
his like pick up boot camp it was here
in Vegas actually yeah he used to live
here yeah yeah yeah and um no he wasn't
actually added he had like instructors
or whatever so yeah he wasn't there but
um yeah and it was I was thinking I was
like wow these guys pay like five grand
yeah for a weekend and yeah they were
just one-on-one with mystery this is 15
years ago was 10K wow just for the
weekend for him and like now would
probably be more expensive than that
yeah maybe a month ago wow about getting
him on here I keep telling Eric I was
like dude everyone's using your name a
lot of people are misinterpreting what
you're saying I'm not super pro pickup I
actually think they got a lot of things
wrong but I look Eric is my friend I
still care about the dude and when I'm
like dude you gotta come out and be a
public face again there's just too many
misconceptions about what happened back
from like 03 to 2011. yeah I heard that
yeah that they scrubbed a lot of stuff
from the internet which I was too bad I
wanted to react so I think you're
referring to RSD scrubbing stuff from
the internet so when Julian Blanc thing
happened where you know he pushed the
girls heads down and then he had to go
do an apology Tour on different shows or
whatever I don't even know what that
Julian block was uh he's a an instructor
for real social dynamics after that
happened two things happened so a guy
named Adam Lyons who was hired to be the
CEO of real social dynamics they were
the biggest dating company in the world
the biggest pickup artist in the world
uh Adam Lyons who's also a pickup artist
he told him he informed Owen Cook he
said listen they just took Alex Jones
down they're gonna take you down so what
you need to do is remove all of this
content of you doing cold approach to
women in nightclubs all of this has got
to go so if you guys notice now RSD does
not have any of that content anymore
that's the reason why that's the reason
why all that content is gone and you'll
notice like a lot of cold approach
content is just not on the internet
because people question not the legality
but the morality of walking up to a
string change woman and then without her
knowing her being picked up and then
taken away for sex and in some cases and
I've actually seen this where pickup
artists will say I pulled the girl and
intimate they had sex and I was there
and I know they didn't uh you see what
I'm saying yeah yeah and so now it's
like there's a tattoo or a dress or like
some other person was there that night
and they're like oh Sally oh Sally
[__] John I was like no Sally didn't
[__] Jon but the video makes it look
like right she did yeah I could see that
and so that was an epidemic where guys
were like they were doing this what's
called Flash game where they were
showing spinning girls around and making
out with girls in clubs yeah girls in
clubs and then they would blink out the
face so you couldn't even tell if the
girl was attractive or not and then
you'd see a picture of them walking out
of the club like a video and then the
intimation was sex then had happened and
99 times out of 100 it didn't happen and
so but it looked good on camera and
there were entire businesses built on
that on that oh wow yeah I mean at the
pickup thing they were just like giving
advice on like how to approach girls and
like you know feedback whatever but yeah
I was like that was when I I was like oh
dating is hard for guys because they're
getting rejected by some whales and I'm
like these guys are better looking than
I mean a couple of them were a bit odd
like one guy had a whole world
domination plan like that was very
interesting
um but yeah it was it kind of gave me
perspective because it was like I was
kind of trying to like help him you know
I was like I'll go after it was kind of
fun I was like go go pick up that one
you know and I was like dang this stuff
is hard I'm curious now that you bring
that up do you have any uh opinion on
the concept of pre-selection or make
Choice copying do you know what I'm
talking about
like it like we want guys that other
girls want
yeah do you believe in the concept like
if I walk up in a club and I have a
beautiful woman with me who introduces
me to another woman I have a better
chance on the intro yeah
um
so because like it's kind of like
because they would kind of use me to
like you know because they called you a
pivot I don't know but yeah but it's
funny because you played in the post in
basketball I don't I don't know which
I mean I'm a bit awkward so it's like I
don't know if I'm the best one to be
here but here's the thing you're still a
woman who is showing
um what's a compliance towards the men
yeah right if the guy says hey let's
walk over here you don't have to like
hold his hand it's just when he walked
to the right you walk to the right also
other women sing even that level of
compliance and the other thing I talk
about is your is your hips if your
pelvis is turned in towards a man and
his is not torn in towards yours and
other women see it that is a there's
this evolutionary hardwiring that causes
them to be like just take notice yeah
well actually when I think if I had a
guy friend in college
um that I was like like super like
platonic or what I know men and women
can't be friends but we they can be
friends we're going to talk about that
but but I would we kind of have this
funny thing where we would just make up
stories at the bar or whatever like
going out and I would and so the one
story we would always say is I'd always
say he was my brother you know he was
Italian
yeah so I would just be like yeah he's
my brother he like helps take care of my
grandma like he's the sweetest God let
me tell you know and just or what
sometimes that we would do outlandish
stories yeah like it didn't even make
him look like I don't know I just think
it's funny
um but yeah that would help like he
definitely would pick up women so so you
do you think men and women can be
friends at all
I mean I think they can't
uh I do and I don't I I think they can
that is the right answer by the way I
think they do and they don't I think
they can but I do think that most men
will always like kind of want to sleep
with you so that kind of changes the
like Dynamic of the Friendship okay um I
know you have your thing where you you
have you have so many women lined up to
sleep with you that you can be their
friend right yeah I mean that's that's a
sorry baby I don't know what you say I
don't know why she's saying that that's
it that's kind of sad or I thought
anyways the actual one is a man who has
enough abundance yeah you what you get
to a point where it's like uh I have my
girlfriend right or let's say I've I've
dated a couple of girls yeah there's
like 12 other girls like when I went to
bulgarian's last party I was with 114
girls wow at some point there's a girl
who brought 30 other girls that's my
[__] friend right there you better
believe that's my friend you want an
Uber I'll buy you an Uber yeah you
understand like there's some people
um two of my close friends Kylie Myers
and CJ Sparks I have no interest in
sleeping with them they're both really
pretty and they've both helped me build
my business that sounds like a friend to
me oh my gosh that was the exception I
was gonna say I do think it can happen
in business a bit more
um because like you're useful to them
it's not just like but I still do think
I'm like an evolutionary level yeah yeah
the answer that I give is that 99 of men
cannot be friends with women they're
attracted to yeah which sounds crazy
coming from me but in the course that I
teach I teach you how to like throw
these events where you're just
surrounded by attractive women all the
time to the point where you don't act
weird you've seen guys act weird when
they approach attractive women yeah
voice deflection goes up Palms start
getting sweaty you started seeing the
dilation of the pupil they start they
talk to they'll talk to me and be like
yo man I'm gonna go over there and talk
to that girl then they can walk over the
girl like hey guys what are you guys
doing you guys want a drink that's a
word you guys want to drink and like and
I say hey bro you were talking to me
like we're about to fight it was like
prison yard [__] over here and now you
go talk to this girl in his lollipop
[__] what's going on here dude yeah keep
the and it's literal constriction of the
vocal cords because you you think that
this woman is high status and so your
vocal cord is constricted you don't want
to come off as a threat you'll notice
the same thing happens when men see
other men that they look up to like
famous athletes or whatever voice and
flexion goes up because of constriction
vocal cords so you're giving High status
people who are used to being approached
by lower status people they're like oh
higher vocal cords okay this is a lower
status process can you I'll tell you the
weirdest thing like now that I've been
because it's crazy the last couple of
months I just get recognized like
everywhere and it's so weird when people
come up to me and like talk to me like
that you know I mean like what they're
so nervous I'm like it's just me like
I'm you know any crazy yeah it's just
weird but I know I know what you're
talking about when they come yeah yeah
yeah and so you'll see you understand
the high status person is getting
approached more than the lowest low
status person is approaching yeah so the
high status person is more used you
could even go like 22 year old hot girl
she's being approached more than the
guys a 22 year old hot girl has been
approached more from the time she went
through puberty to the time she's 22
then I will be approaching my entire
life correct so she's more used to the
low status approaching of her so she's
more quick to see those signs which is
something that pickup Artistry doesn't
do a good job of fixing what I what I
tell men to do is you need to be
immersed it's funny when I talk about
can men and women be friends you know
what I never have this argument with
guys who manage strip clubs guys who
worked as VIP hosts male strippers dudes
who are like Club promoters or dudes who
are bartenders whenever I talk to them
or male nurses whenever I talk to them
can men and women be friends they're
like [__] yeah of course yeah why
because they're they're never worried
about women today they're constantly
surrounded by beautiful women if you're
talking about a [__] E3 at Fort Hood
in in Colleen Texas who hasn't seen a
woman in [__] 15 months because he
just deployed to Iraq and he got back no
he cannot be friends with women yes can
you again uh the best best example I
ever heard was Justin Waller he says I'm
not afraid of a bad man I'm afraid of a
desperate man right so it's desperation
that causes that yeah like when I was
talking to Jedediah Billy the other day
I was like man I would beat this girl
would be my best friend if we were
[__] hanging out I would love to hang
out with Jedediah yeah this is so cool
we can make content together she's got
really cool ideas we would disagree
about [__] and it would be funny and and
what Justin Waller says is if we can't
make money together I don't want to be
your [__] friend that comes off as
really shallow but I only have so many
friend slots in my life and if I'm
trying to turn my business into an
eight-figure business my friend slots
are filled by people who can get me to
eight figures men or women you see what
I'm saying so so that was one of the
things that I thought was like I think
it's very reductive to just say men and
women can't be friends men of scarcity
cannot be friends correct men of
abundance can easily be friends with
women so you would say that but 99 of
the time they can't be friends because
most men are sims yeah yeah absolutely
okay okay fair there's 50 million men on
uh only fans and one million content
creators yeah no I was just thinking
that's probably like more of the
exception than the rule yes yeah but the
thing is if you just did a couple of
things fix your social media started
like getting involved with big charity
events inviting hundreds of girls at
these different events like started
having container events you're just a
dude who has a boat you just have a
[__] big boat that you can take girls
out every weekend you're gonna have
female friends you're gonna have the two
girls you're sleeping with and then
Sally who brings three other girls every
time and you're not sleeping with Sally
because you know Sally's boyfriend but
you still bring Sally on the thing and
when Sally's birthday comes around you
throw a big [__] birthday party
because Sally keeps bringing four girls
on your boat every time when you're a
club promoter you know you have to have
female friends because what you said
about being useful but it's not just
women being useful my friends are useful
period unless you're somebody I grew up
with in high school my friends are all
useful I relate you know what I'm saying
yeah my friends are all of you so that's
so true oh that's so true that's the way
the way you got to look at it is not can
men and women be friends it's like who
is competent and useful in your life
those are your [__] friends right
something else about CJ the reason why
CJ Sparks Kylie Myers and Caitlin Rucker
like are uh uh Caitlin Frank are like my
three close female friends there was a
situation where all three of them had a
very easy would have a very easy time
turning their back on me
and instead they gave me some
information about some people who were
doing some nefarious [__] behind my back
when they didn't have to um and two of
those girls are like million plus
followers blue check mark before you
could buy a blue check mark they were
they were pretty famous they went out of
their way to help me and show me a level
of loyalty when they didn't have to and
we weren't sleeping together that's why
they're my friends wow A friend is
somebody who's going to go out of their
way when a friend is not a friend when
it's convenient a friend is a friend
when it's inconvenient right when it was
inconvenient for those three girls they
didn't turn their back they actually
helped me out that's where they're my
friend and so a lot of dudes would be
like well that's not you know most women
are like that you're [__] correct
most women are not like that I agree
that's why it's so unique in those
situations I look at people loyal people
are loyal intelligent people are
intelligent doesn't matter if they're
men or women on average do I find that
most men uh keep their word more than
women yeah I do I do but it but you can
find different things that's why when
the question is can men and women
reference the answers yes are most of
women men and women capable being
friends the answer is no that's that's
what I believe at least that's what the
stats have shown me right right
David Buss talks about
um it's called kinship Theory basically
the idea of men and women like women
trying to acquire as many male female
male friends as they can to help them
with survivability but only sleeping
with like one of them right it's a
theory and you see this women often will
try to get attention from multiple men
uh sometimes wow right okay so it's
kinship Theory and evolutionary
psychology
um and the other thing is I'll just say
for men out there who are listening to
this maybe you've never heard this
before women will acclimate you to being
around beautiful women you don't get the
constriction of the voice and the sweaty
palms and all that kind of stuff you get
used to it we in the U.S military they
they fire live bullets at you when you
let you get behind a berm and they fire
live bullets over your head and you get
used to hearing what that sounds like
the first time you hear live bullets
over your head your heart rate's like
140. then the next time it's like at 90.
then the next time you're just your
heart is like oh it's just bullets going
over my head I know not to stand up but
I'm not freaking out anymore the first
time you see the hottest woman in your
life you come to Vegas the first time
you see her you're freaking out about
the tenth time you come down here it's
just not that big of a deal anymore
which is why I encourage men to get used
to being around women who are attractive
like what they like so that when you
meet that dream girl that you want to
marry and she's stunning you're not
acting like a [__] weirdo you see
what I'm saying uh number two women give
you access uh like I get invited to
every party because I have a ton of
female girls that I have a ton of girls
with me and number three women introduce
you to more women that's true yeah yeah
that's true and so that's why I've set
up so many people I really help people
find love love on the pregame you know
I'm a set upper oh we're gonna try to
find someone for you actually
um so that let's talk about with
friendship
um
as this happens to a lot of my clients
it's happened to me a lot of people from
my previous life my past life are like
Bro you've changed I remember you used
to be like this yeah right you had an
incident happen with a previous friend
where she made some public comments
about you uh you can go into what those
comments were but how did that affect
you and like how were you able to deal
with that
uh yeah that was I was very surprised
that she did that to be honest
um well she actually I stopped being
friends with her like a a while ago so
this wasn't like recent
um and what happened was I was making
some comments about fat chicks and I was
talking about how you shouldn't and I
think this is basic like we shouldn't
gain a bunch of weight after you get
married yeah like I think that's kind of
like not being a good wife she had
gained a bunch of weight I hadn't seen
her in a while it wasn't about her but
the thing was like she kept like trying
to get me to like every time she'd watch
my show and just be like oh you can't
say that you can't like because she was
kind of feminist and
um like and I was always fine like that
was kind of outside of our friendship
you know
um and we just you know before you could
just like talk about other stuff once
you go online like your friends see all
your opinions and yeah and so she said
she wanted to stop being my friends and
it was weird because when I said okay
fine like you you said this and then she
got like really mad and what I realized
is like women can kind of be like
spiteful and the problem is like with
girls is though they'll kind of like
take a half truth and kind of spin I
don't even I don't even remember what
she said to be honest I just remember
being like well that wasn't really true
you know I just remember like watching
it and thinking but what I realized is
like
I can't really control people and um
yeah that was it was sad but because I
was friends with her for like 20 years
one of the issues is that she went
public with it and started making
content based on your relationship with
her like showing old photos and stuff
like that oh I didn't do that no she did
yes she did yeah that's what I'm talking
about yeah it's very it reminds me very
similar of like a horrible situation
with uh Justin Waller's Mom I don't know
if you've ever seen this thing but just
as long as Mom starts like saying stuff
that like clearly wasn't true yeah about
Justin and I thought it was so low brow
of like certain certain somebody to
interview her when that whole thing
happened but it's one of these things
where it's like you're not a content
creator but all of a sudden you're
trying to become famous off this thing
yeah well yeah she was like oh she's
never had a boyfriend but I'm like what
are you talking about I just had I don't
know so I was like what I don't know she
was kind of nutty yeah but um I wasn't
like crazy shocked because I I don't
know it was kind of a weird thing with
her where I always felt like
um how do I put it like I felt like we
were like closer when we were younger
and like I don't know if you've ever had
someone like from high school where you
like your life just kind of gets like
better and there's like doesn't so they
kind of like Get out of shape I kind of
I have 20 or 30 friends that went to
jail for selling crack cocaine oh gosh
okay well she wasn't that bad but but it
was it's just like I just feel like her
life wasn't really like going the way it
wanted and I kind of felt this kind of
drifting apart like a couple years
earlier and it's kind of a weird thing
with women where you can kind of feel
like I'm getting kind of like jealous of
you because you know
I'm trying not to like say too much but
I felt like like she was always like my
my pretty friend you know what I mean
that she got kind of you know and I it's
weird I felt like our Dynamics sort of
like changed after that yeah because I I
don't know but yeah yeah I'm trying to
not get in trouble again I don't know
yeah no I understand I don't need
another 10 videos made about me the
thing that I think is interesting is is
I want to make a statement that it's not
good for you to have a super high BMI
it's difficult uh on your heart it's
difficult on your health it's difficult
on your joints yeah if I make that
statement that it's unhealthy to be at
that weight yeah that does not make me a
misogynist that does not make me a fat
shamer I'm making a statement and I can
show you thank you
evidence to base what I'm saying I also
don't hate you because I made that
statement okay now uh you know Nicole
Arbor you remember when she said dear
fat people have you ever seen that video
she made I I've heard of it yeah so
Nicole Nicole Nicole got sick of La just
moved to [__] Nashville because she
was tired of yeah dealing with all this
[__] uh Nicole makes that video now
she's being a little bit more satirical
and she attacks some people a little bit
and and at the end she's like Hey fat
people I love you that's why I'm saying
this yeah but it goes back to what we
said before when I when I talked to the
girls who did only fans and I didn't say
I hate you I didn't call you a name I
just said here is a possible consequence
for your behavior then I was called a
misogynist right when I go off and you
say something the effective it is not a
good idea for you to weigh this much we
haven't gotten into the Attraction part
yeah I'm that doesn't make me a pig for
saying that it's probably not a good
idea for you to weigh this much but what
makes it even more Insidious is this
[__] here so the 37 culture study done
in 1989 by Dr David Buss where he looks
at these 39 cultures they have nothing
to do with each other people from Papaya
New Guinea Yama Mama Indians people from
who live in the Andes they have no radio
television or film and they looked for a
small a perf a certain hip to waist
ratio about 0.72 yeah hip to waist ratio
in all of these cultures they look for
signs of Youth and signs of fertility
which means that
uh beauty is not subjective it's
actually objective you can actually see
there was this one study they've done
they've done it several times before
they do like a psychology 101 course and
they take everyone's picture they
superimpose them all over each other and
they get the average of all the faces
and that face is more attractive than
anyone in the course does that make
sense because it's a symmetrical face
so we know from that that beauty is
subjective and beauty is the
subjectivity of I'm sorry beauty is
objective and the objectivity of beauty
is implanted in US based on our genetics
that's why when you have the discussion
about whether or not men prefer very
obese women versus very skinny women
this is not the argument I always hear
is like no cultures telling me to not
accept women for being overweight and my
response to that is no here is
unassailable proof of this study of 37
cultures that proves that's not the case
and there's also studies where they show
like children stare at more attractive
faces for longer which means this is
hardwired into our genetics my
heterosexuality and my belief in like
what I find attractive is not a cultural
construct it is genetic that is
offensive to a lot of people the idea of
that whole thing happening that beauty
is objective and not subjective well and
the other thing that we were talking
about in the podcast she got mad about
was how like husbands are afraid to like
say this to their wives that they want
them to lose weight and I just don't
think that's fair like I I really don't
think it's fair and you know what else I
realized through this whole thing I'm
like people really it doesn't matter
like what you do for someone it's like
if they feel spotted like they're very
like there's no loyalty in a way uh like
that girl like literally we'd let her
stay with us in the Summers wow like for
free I'm like you know yeah she could
still have that opinion and then not
make tick tocks on it because I thought
yeah or keep it between you and the
other person yeah yeah so
um you know what's funny we you know
talk about different aspects of
masculinity one of the aspects that
doesn't get brought up enough is the
concept of like standing behind your
tribe even when they're wrong right yeah
so I agree like with the roller with the
whole tweet with the ma with the
vasectomy thing all these people start
attacking him and I'm like my first
instance you know Kevin Garnet obviously
yeah Kevin Garnett does this one
interview and he says if one of my
teammates gets into a fight I'm jumping
in on his side yeah I don't know what
the fight's over but you put your hands
on my teammate we're [__] going down
yeah when we get into the locker room
privately I'm gonna ask you okay bro
what happened why did we get into a
fight right when they go after Rolo
Rolo's my friend even if I don't agree
with everything he said like I think
he's too hard on you even if I don't
agree with everything Rolo says he's
still my friend I was gonna defend him
no matter what then when he we talk
about like oh I actually agree with you
this is stupid obviously you didn't
actually mean vasectomy he was just
saying this to be hyperbolic and it's
one of those situations where we uh
another example uh the guys I understood
the Tweet yeah I agreed with him like
with raw hello like um I mean I don't I
understood what he was saying he was
talking about it's the fastest way the
fastest the quickest way yeah and the
only foolproof way really is a vasectomy
like yeah I'm not saying do it but I
understood it was the 10 out of 10. like
10 out of 10 idiot proof way of doing it
that's what he was saying yeah and I
understood like so I was like I'm on
your side but it's okay yeah people
people just like took it out of context
yeah we had a long debate about it yeah
the thing is in the end he won because
like Ben Shapiro's not talking about me
right now she's not talking about me
correct you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah in the end he did win yeah
um so but I thought it was interesting
when men stand up for their friends or
for their tribe and then in this case
you have a woman who was part of your
tribe and she doesn't she just sells you
up the [__] River I think it's
masculine to stand behind your friends
even when they're wrong but then to
privately let them know hey bro this is
what we should be doing different and I
and what I'm seeing instead though is a
lot of very unmasculine men going off
and selling out their friends snitching
on their friends trying to steal your
girlfriend behind your back that seems
to be more of the case one of the funny
things that happens to me is because we
said before I have a ton of female
friends well my guy friends go to my
female friends and they start running
their mouth about me I find out about it
immediately I'm like bro you're a snitch
you understand what I'm saying that's so
true guys run they'll run their mouth
like I the amount of information I'm
like George Tennant bro I got so much
CIA information and they don't realize
that because they run their mouth to
these girls and they think the girls are
going to be loyal to them and that's not
the way it works right when you're not
loyal as a dude to me that's like worse
than anything that's why I never you'll
never even people that I don't like you
won't hear me talking bad about them
behind their back because this passive
aggression you know you know that
happened to me with the co-host right
like I had a CO oh I had a co-host that
like came out and said I was a colonizer
yeah you hear about that yeah
specifically like colonizer like the
Imperial appearance I guess okay yeah I
guess you know blessings here against
his Free Will apparently well right yeah
that's funny no but it's yeah it's crazy
it's crazy the social media just like
changes social dynamics because there's
like money and throwing people under the
bus correct so that's so yeah my point
is it's not feminine but it's
non-masculine to throw your friends yes
that's like it's masculine to go to jail
for your homie and not snitch that is
masculine that is the reason why it's
masculine is because your ancestors were
willing to die for the tribe that is
masculinity the ultimate form of
masculinity is willing to die for your
tribe right okay the ultimate form of
not I'm not gonna call femininity I'm
call it non-masculinity the ultimate
form of non-masculinity is willing to
snitch on your homies steal his girl
does that make sense yeah because I'm
thinking like that's how do they get to
the men they would always like like
bring a woman and you know what I mean
like like have the girl sleep yeah
that's what happened with um Petraeus
General Petraeus was the head of the CIA
and he had to step down because he was
cheating on his wife with a reporter
well once like if foreign service
agencies what's our genius I'm sorry
yeah once foreign service agencies find
out that you're cheating on your wife
they can use it to Blackmail you sound
like a nine yeah
yeah all right so let's talk about this
you had uh Andrew Tate on your um show
about 72 hours before he was arrested
somewhere in that area was it I don't
think it was that it was it you were it
was in December it was pretty close he
was arrested on December 30 30th and you
had him on pretty close to that oh yeah
well it was like the maybe like the 10th
or something oh so
yeah we dropped the video we had like a
whole commercial for it so we dropped it
like super okay because that's why I was
confused yeah yeah yeah
um in that whole instance what did you
think about having them on what did you
think about the reaction what do you
think about that whole the whole thing I
thought that panel was genius I think
that was the best panel I ever put
together
um I I'm just like who would have
thought put Brittany Renner on a panel
of Dance I thought of it you know
um because whenever I put together a
panel I'm always trying to put two
people on like opposite ends yeah I
wanted Amber Rose imagine if I got Amber
Rose but I didn't think of it but um
well she her fee was like 30k I'm like I
don't want you that bad the problem the
problem with Anna Rose Amber Rose as
opposed to Brittany Renner is Amber Rose
is not out there trying Andrew Rose is
just openly saying I have sex with men
whenever I want and I'm not ashamed of
it right yeah but she's not trying to
benefit human beings Brittany Renner at
the end of your interview said one of
the most appalling things I've ever
[__] heard anyone say she goes I
believe that my voice is necessary in
this space and I'm like [__] how
there's videos of you saying you [__]
three guys in one day and your vagina
hurts how and you don't even denounce
those videos please explain to me why
I've not seen that one yes yeah dude
it's really bad like look at the ones
like when she was in college I know I've
seen some but I see the three guys oh
god well she's like talking oh my vagina
hurts because I have [__] three guys
once one day and I'm like my whole thing
is like like you're telling me now that
your voice needs to be hurt I don't I
agree you're you have a right to an
opinion I love uh quantum mechanics but
there's already guys doing podcasts on
that my voice is not necessary in that
space yeah does that make sense like
there's already guys doing NBA podcasts
my voice is not necessarily in the space
the idea that for male or female
self-improvement your voice is necessary
in the space like how dare you that [__]
was crazy to me like what you could do
is say hey I made some mistakes yeah
because I made the mistakes here's what
I can do to help you get moved forward
she's not even doing that though she's
not even like saying she [__] up
before she's saying I [__] up now how
do we fix the world to accept what I did
bro what you did to PJ Washington was
[__] terrible and you deserve the
chat like hey you want to go to [__]
Charlotte Bobcats game with me because I
bet you aren't going to be allowed to go
in like what happened there is like so
bad and she doesn't accept the
responsibility for what she did that's
the difference that's why I think
Brittany Renner was a better guest than
Amber Rose you see what I'm saying yeah
Brittany Renner is going to try to cope
which makes for better content right
Amber Rose is not going to try to coat
Amber Rose is going to be like I'm a hoe
thank you go for it I appreciate my
wholeness I'm for everybody they find us
at every party you know I'm saying ain't
gonna be loyal not for anybody yeah
that's that's the difference but yeah
yeah I met Amber Rose at the Playboy
Mansion one time oh did you
I don't know her fee was crazy I was
like yeah I can't do that but but yeah
so we had
um Brittany Runner
um then two guests from the show
um on on and Andrew was really I mean
people always ask me what he was like
but he was so quick in and out like he
were working on like a time crunch so it
was like he walked through the door we
sat him down we started filming and then
he left so but he was super nice um I
was supposed to go to Dubai actually for
it yeah and I actually I lost like 15
000 because my old assistant didn't get
trip insurance or anything and I was
like kill myself
um so it was don't clip that but I went
but yeah we were all supposed to go to
Dubai and film it and then my passport
expired within six months I didn't know
they wouldn't let me in the country I'm
American I'm spoiled I'm like what they
won't let me in but I'm American I'm
like what I've never dealt with this
before yeah I thought I could get into
anywhere yet not the case so we had to
cancel that whole trip and then he ended
up coming which was like really nice
yeah so yeah that was really cool man I
thought it was I really thought we
enjoyed how it seemed like his tone and
tenor made the even the people who
didn't like him they started listening
to him more it's almost like they felt
like the whole panel was kind of on his
side there by the end of it yeah I mean
I even learned things from him during
that panel because he like the way he
explained like just uh I can't remember
what it was now but just certain things
from like the point of view of a guy I
was like I've never thought about like
how to get the guy to stop playing video
games and he was like why don't you guys
say it like this I was like yeah I
should yeah I should it was two years
yeah yeah one of my favorite analogies
that he uses is that like when like the
amount of work that I did to buy this
yacht compared to be on this yacht
versus the amount of work that those
models in
Monaco did to be on this yacht when you
were in your early 20s you were not
interested in monogamy but now I'm being
judged in my mid-40s for not being
interested in monogamy yeah that's what
I that's what's interesting um like
women like we pick non-monogamy yeah
yeah that yeah that was one of the
topics is like when I if you were to
talk to Mia Khalifa or Lana Rose in
their early 20s and said are you
interested in monogamy now they'd be
like no and then if you said do you
think that older men should be willing
to date you even though you're in early
20s I guarantee you they would have said
yes yeah then later on when all sudden
they're not in that age bracket anymore
now Mia Khalifa says well there's
something wrong with men who want to
date younger women and I'm like no
you're just not a younger woman anymore
yeah you weren't interested you were
very much interested in older men when
you were younger and by the way maybe
she wasn't maybe she's the exception
most women in their early 20s if you ask
them would you date a handsome what like
uh 38 year old man who's doing well and
is financially secure they would be like
yes it was interesting oh my gosh I
really did not look at guys that much
older than me when I was my like 21 22.
my mom was like don't don't date guys
too old that's like the funny thing yeah
because you the whole thing like you
have kids and then they'll be geriatric
or something like that no no like when I
was like 21 or 22 like when or in
college my mom was like don't date like
like guys that are too much like in
their 30s or anything which is
interesting because I don't know if that
was good advice or not my girlfriend
didn't realize I was over 40 when we met
and I didn't realize that she was under
21 when we met oh my she's under 21. oh
she's 21 now oh wow I'm 24 years older
than her yeah oh wow I have no idea and
if you hang out with her she seems so
much more mature no I'm surprised I
thought she was like mid late 20s yeah
yeah it's crazy wow um I mean she's
beautiful though yeah she's she's
awesome yeah she's so cool I I picked
her because she'd be down to kill
somebody for me and I don't want her to
kill anybody for me but like if somebody
was like jumping on my back she's down
to do whatever like this the Loyalty
does that make sense how'd you meet her
I was hosting swimsuit USA's World
Championship I'm one of the hosts for
that oh that's awesome and she was a
finalist for that she'd done like
multiple pageants maybe 20 30 pageants
before that and then she did swimsuit
USA's world championship and then I met
her there and we just hit it off and at
first she didn't take it seriously and I
was like no this you're the girl I want
for sure 100 and then I flew her out and
then she moved in a couple months later
and she's been with me for the last uh
since October 27th oh wow yep that's
pretty much how it's worked
um so she was so cool I just I liked her
and whatever yeah I was a fan when she
was talking to the like only fans chicks
or whatever I was like you tell them
yeah it was interesting like yeah the
thing is here's the thing people were
offended by that clip but in the
beginning of the clip she literally says
you can do only fans if you want yeah no
one it's like they don't they don't
commute or compute like even if I say
I'm not talking about you yeah I'm not
talking about you personally then
they're like but I and I'm like isn't it
crazy it's like the qualifier is there
and you're still offended yeah that's to
me it's like you're not arguing in good
faith at that point right let's have a
that's why the thing with me and Destiny
went so well is because Destiny kept
bringing up evolutionary psychology
studies that's my specialty so I loved
that debate he didn't call me [__]
names now he said I was a Coke had on
one of his live streams he doesn't know
me I've never tried Coke in my life I
get it but like when we met in person
there was no ad hominem attacks I
appreciate that do that but what happens
is you have these discussions with
people and you just use just just a a
squirt of consequences just this might
happen to you yeah you [__]
misogynist and it's like it hurts more
here's the other thing I found when I
say it's my opinion it hurts when I can
show studies that hurts so much more
well and it's like what outcomes does
this lead to and like that's what that's
what I'm always saying like what what
outcomes does this craziness lead to for
women like why I just don't like liars
and I just hate it and I hate it when
Sims do this too they act like there's
no consequences for women when they and
it irritates me more because I'm like
you guys know you know deep down why are
they doing that though because they're
trying to get laid yes yes they know
again like the anthem go everybody go
listen to Juicy J they're for everybody
they're for everybody yeah but but you
know what I love about that song he goes
they for everybody but I still love
these hoes and he knows they go in this
category yeah right it's an extreme
example no yeah but but Juicy J saying
the the they for everybody you they're
not gonna be loyal now for anybody yeah
but I love these hoes he keeps them over
here they're not his wife
they're for everybody but he understands
that and so that's the difference for me
is like I do whatever you want to do I'm
going to explain to you some
consequences I'm going to show you some
math about these consequences it's going
to be harder for you to stay in a
relationship if you've had sex with 50
men your just your neurology is
different when you have sex with 50 men
forget about the morality of it go ahead
yeah well I think of it like alcohol
like if you drink alcohol every day
you're not gonna get as drunk when you
drink it if you have sex with every like
a new guy every single day you're not
going to follow us in love when you do
it yeah Myron was he likes to use
adhesive tape it's like every time I
pull the tape off yeah it sticks less oh
they use that in Cal you got that from
Catholic School Purity things that's
what they would they would I we had
Chastity speakers every year yes okay if
you want to do that that's fine but the
other thing that's crazy to me is when
women brag to me they're like oh I can
have sex without feelings I'm like don't
brag about it just like ladies just be
quiet like you just pull out your dick
at that point you're that's a masculine
trait why are you bragging about a
masculine trait do you understand yeah
and when you tell me that you know what
that makes me think okay cool you'd be
fun you're e for everybody let me you
know for recreational use only I'll have
sex with you and then I'll just move on
because you just said you can do it
without feelings that actually makes me
less likely to want to be with you
because I know I can have sex with you
you're not going to trip about it but
here's the thing they still trip about
it they still trip about like the girl
who says I don't catch any feelings when
she Mets the guy who absolutely doesn't
catch any feelings for her then she
catches feelings
well what well and it's crazy I asked
the girl on the show that slept with 200
guys how many how many did you actually
like love or like were you like did you
actually really like guess how many she
said out of 200 guess I want to see if
you
I need to ask you a question if this is
the girl real quick out of uh she
probably four
you're close five that's what she said
um
I was like how do you find 200 people
you I don't even know 200 people
oh my God I have to know if this is the
girl because I didn't she just wrote me
there's a girl that said she slept with
a hundred on my show too and she said
around five too okay can we talk about
that so she got mad because she said her
body count and then she called you out
for it which which one just the girl
with the 200 no okay no no I was about
to hit her up and be like she was the
girl sitting right across from you she
was outside oh I remember she was cool
she was cool yeah
um so
you said you had a girl come on your
show and you you said do body counts
matter and just to prove the point girls
do not say what their body count is yeah
and then you said do you want to say
your body count and the girl set her
body count and then later on had tried
to sue you because you posted it raised
like 10 thousand dollars to sue me
pounds I'm like you guys are her
objective was to get that pulled off no
okay so this was fairly early this was
super early when I first started the
show so this is like like the audio was
so bad this episode anyway
um but yeah so it was an episode on body
count and I was like all right guys to
start the show what's your body count
hahaha I say never mind you don't have
to say it and there's a guy there and a
girl it's three of us and the guy was
like yeah cool I'm not you know and the
girl was like oh I'll say it and I'm
like are you sure she says she's sure
I'm here for the content yes see here's
the microphone and she said now get him
on these whatever shows this sounds low
compared to these girls but she was like
like 30 or something and I was like whoa
that's wild and she um so whatever she's
body positive we have a whole
conversation about this yeah at the end
of the show I say would you come back
she says yes okay and also in the
beginning of the show so lady if you're
watching this just so you know I have
texts of you confirming what podcast you
were coming on and knowing where you
were going so stop with this I didn't
know [__] I have text to prove this
lady that raised ten thousand dollars to
sue me she's keeping that money you
idiots all the guy people that gave her
money she's just keeping it like stupid
sorry I just need to get that out there
but but um she freaking
um yeah and then she just wanted me to
take the stream down and I just think
like I put so much work to put on these
shows I can't pull it you can blur out
words after the fact in it's in YouTube
Studio pretty sure you can
if that's a big an issue I think I would
do that no it takes a while because it
has to re-render the entire video yeah
I've done it before yeah but it was for
copyrighted music I cut some of it out
in the middle of the video but like that
that is I'm just no like I'm not I'm
gonna say do it outside that's a
possibility instead of taking it down
yeah no well my thing is no I pay I pay
money to put this on we tell you before
it's live and she knew it was live so
it's like if you want to say it this is
not like you're a grown adult and men
have said things and gotten roasted for
it and they don't do like have the same
reaction but women do yeah um but yeah
so then she said she was gonna sue me
and then she was like autistic and that
she couldn't consent and like I was like
sort of taking I don't know for those of
you don't know here's your next public
service announcement if you are on a
tick tock video YouTube someone is
filming and you put your mouth up to a
microphone that implies legal consent
there is your warning you cannot after
the fact say I was recorded without my
knowledge you see it's big and black and
fuzzy right here okay this you know when
you see the the microphone even if you
see a lavalier if you see anything if
someone holds up a an iPhone to your
face if you speak into a microphone that
is the implication of legal consent Jack
demo actually told me that he's a
Canadian YouTuber and he was explaining
that oh yeah she has no ground to stand
on of course she's just stealing y'all's
money so good luck with that people you
made a video not too long ago I do
appreciate you doing these videos like
you're putting your makeup on you're
like in your hotel you start talking
about like after a workout you start
talking about women need to improve yes
okay the two things you talked about was
STDs what I want to ask you a couple
things the stats that you like to quote
which are the ones that you think are
the most over like crazy ones one that I
remember 40 of women who have had an
abortion have had a second abortion
they've had at least two and then you
talked about the thing with STDs what
are specifically some of these things
that you were talking about where women
need to improve oh
um
the first one is obesity okay I just I
think we can all get like there's so
many men's improvements right so like
and when you look at the men's
Improvement stuff like fresh and fit
whoever it's like actual Improvement
like get in shape in you right you have
your whole thing like throw these
charity events this is how you can do
that women's Improvement it's like it's
so weird I like study this stuff it's
like journaling yeah confidence I'm like
what and therapy we can talk about that
too
therapy and I am in I am in a psychology
program currently sort of I'm half
dropped out I don't know if I'll finish
it was I just wanted an easy program
we're just gonna yeah I don't actually
care about it but
these women are crazy that are
therapists do not I'm telling you these
therapists will make you more crazy and
I say this I am in school with these
therapists ladies don't do it crazy
ladies now
um yeah so I was saying like women need
to improve because it's like
like men are actually like their
self-improvement is about improving but
ours isn't it's about problem solving
yeah and so you know it's not about
feeling good it's about problems yeah so
it's a good good self-improvement yeah
so it's like maybe don't sleep with the
entire football team you know maybe we
could start there I know you can't undo
what's you know happened before yeah but
we could you know maybe not sleep with
the entire football team right
um and then on top of that it's like
we're so overweight it's like 70 60 70
of us are overweight so maybe 32 of
women are obese like extremely obese
yeah yeah so I'm like maybe we could
start by getting in shape that's number
one
um maybe not sleeping with everybody uh
maybe
yeah if if you think that I'm shaming
you because you're overweight that's
fine you can have that opinion it's not
a valid opinion but you can have it well
you can have the opinion is then me
saying you being weighing less would not
make you more objectively attractive
yeah that's when we're getting into just
like Lulu like [__] lunacy like of
course you want to know what the number
one aphrodisiac is for your man be in
shape you know the best dating coach is
for a woman is a personal trainer it is
as shallows you may think that is I will
just show you study after study of what
men find attractive and there's a
difference this is a big one and rollo's
the one who taught me this there's a
difference between personal self-worth
and a sexual market value
for men personal self-worth and sexual
market value often it's the same they're
often the same yeah my competency my
self-worth and my my stature and even my
speaking voice make me higher value to
other men and higher value to women
women's personal self-worth like Madame
Curie who discovered radium they ended
up dying of cancer right that's an
incredible thing that she did though
like discovered like radioactive decay
that's [__] amazing but that didn't
make her husband's penis harder yeah
because she discovered radium in fact he
may have died also from from radiation
poisoning I don't know I don't know the
answers I just started looking up some
numbers and I was like it said one in
three women have had an STD at some
point in their life okay so to be fair I
think that may include uh UTIs I think
that number may include UTIs okay I
think that maybe would work because that
one in three is a crazy number but yeah
it may I may be wrong yeah I know I've
seen somewhere where a urinary tract
infection meaning biome from their
outside of their vagina yeah that goes
into their vagina causes a tract
infection because they don't piss after
they yeah this was from this is from the
CDC okay so you know I I don't know this
is just what this from what I understand
UTI would be considered I could be wrong
somebody wants to correct me and it was
like one in three women have had an
abortion okay right and then it was like
90 of women have been on birth control
at some point in their life for now
you're telling me 43 of us are
overweight it was either 60 to 70
percent of us are oh wait sorry 43 will
be 60 to 70 overweight or obese yeah
um
when it comes to loyalty you know we're
the ones leaving marriages
um we leave 70 to 80 percent of the time
90 if we're college educated it's like
how can we look at this as a whole and
just say you know we're doing a good job
ladies it's like maybe we should improve
a bit and so we we have the wife school
that we did a lot of people think I'm
teaching it I'm really tired of this
narrative everyone's like Pearl's
teaching wife school I'm not teaching it
I bring in like wives or women that have
been in like long-term relationships for
a long time and they just teach like
basic skills on you know being a wife so
like I learned how to cook for a family
of four or one episode I learned how to
knead bread another episode not that
that's you know you got to do that but
it was fun yeah it's amazing I'm
actually interested in seeing what some
of the stuff you put on there yeah yeah
I did um the first what did I do the
first episode
um I'm gonna I'm gonna get a kid for a
day okay wow that's a good one yeah yeah
watch some children yeah um yeah so it's
just going through like skills that you
know you could learn that's terrific
yeah that's terrific
um let's talk about this real quick
um I'm gonna name some people and you
just give me your impression of them
okay okay uh you said you having
something with hotep Jesus okay what is
what is your thing there oh hotep
um
you know I yeah I I kind of in
see I want to start I don't want to
start beef
um he's cool guy cool guy he's always
tweeting at me like grifter or whatever
and I'm just like yeah you don't deserve
my fire tweets what I'm saying is like
he he didn't seem acrimonious at all
when he interviewed you so why is where
do you think this this hat came from no
he was kind of a bit when he interviewed
me yeah I I just thought he was trying
to get like a gotcha moment like in the
interview I don't know it's interesting
because I kind of thought like we all go
into interviews like trying to have a
conversation and what I realized is a
lot of people are going into interviews
like trying to get a 30 second like buzz
clip or like or they're very like like
they Their audience thinks one thing and
if they go against Their audience or
nice to you like I didn't realize it was
kind of like like that uh where because
I'm just like I came in trying to have a
convo so that was kind of how I took it
but you know just just mainly he's
tweeting that you're a grifter yeah and
I just thought it was just you know I
don't really have a strong opinion on
him either way I just felt like he
didn't deserve my fire tweets anymore
Nick Fuentes no he's a nice guy yeah um
he's a nice guy um I think he's got some
crazy opinions but yeah he was he was
very nice on the show on on a scale of
crazy opinions which do you think is the
craziest and could you rank him oh gosh
because he here's what I see when I see
now yeah I see like and I see the same
thing with Alex Jones and a bunch of
other people where it's like like 80
percent of the time somewhere between 50
and 80 of the time they're saying these
rational things that like follow along
with like moderate conservatism and
you're like oh that sounds great that
sounds like a great idea and then it's
like and then the races shouldn't mix
and I'm like oh wait a second I agreed
with everything else he said wait should
I just agree with this also am I also a
white supremacist yeah it's like he just
take it it's a sales technique by the
way if you don't know this this is a
common sales technique you get a bunch
of yeses well you know I think women
should be more moral I think we should
go along with the Bible it's like man
that guy's making a lot of sense and
then he just breaks off with the [__]
crazy [__] yeah and you're like oh [__]
this is the part where you're asking for
my credit card because then I'm going to
join you with the white supremacy got it
okay yeah oh the Holocaust didn't happen
no just all those dudes just disappeared
they just went up in an alien spaceship
got it well and a lot of the stuff he
was talking about I didn't really know
like have I studied the freaking
Holocaust no I don't know
um so I mean number one that's probably
the craziest one
um two is the race mixing stuff but it
sounded really similar the stuff Dr Umar
says I mean it's I've heard that before
from like the older generation you know
it's not my opinion but yeah it's
probably out of the interview that's
probably the two big ones he it's really
funny because it's really [__] up so I
don't agree with the oh oh and he's Pro
he believes in like I've never met
anyone that's a fan of Stalin yeah I was
like yeah that was crazy yeah that's the
whole thing yeah yeah so that maybe
Stalin would be two I don't know Joseph
Stalin was so [__] stupid that at one
point when the German Army got all the
way to within two kilometers of the
Kremlin he had an intelligence officer
come to him and say you know uh chairman
we we you know the Germans are here we
have to do something about it he had the
man tortured
for telling him the truth
that's how [__] dumb this guy was yes
dude you guys want to go to Stalin we
can go into style but the thing is I I
haven't watched enough Nick points did
you see what happens to me in interviews
yeah you'll say this right and then
they'll be like Pearl push back I don't
yeah I don't know here's the thing with
with with with Nick this is what I see
and by the way I am not qualified to
speak on Nick Fuentes because I've just
seen a couple of Clips yeah he feels to
me like
if I was going to draw the conservative
that liberals would use to fight against
conservatives if that makes any sense
yeah if they were going to point out a
specific conservative to use as the
spokesperson to why all conservatism is
wrong and I don't feel as a conservative
I'm slightly right of Center I don't
feel like he represents me so when I
hear him I feel like he's almost a
caricature of a white supremacist does
that make sense like he's almost like a
draw like a Rick and Morty drawing of
what a white supremacist is supposed to
look like rather than actually being a
white supremacist it's kind of weird I
don't know I don't like I feel like he's
I feel like he's two hairs away from
telling me the Earth is flat like that's
what it feels like with me because if it
got him more views I feel like he'd say
that he doesn't believe that I I don't
you know that flat earthers get their
beliefs from The Book of Genesis it says
that there's a firmament over us that's
what they get it from I don't know yeah
I'm not into I don't know about that but
he's he's a nice guy he's actually he's
super nice is Gary grinsberg the [__]
uh Gary the numbers guy so [__] nice
to ask me now to go to dinner afterwards
yeah and then he just says this like
horrible stuff on there yeah and
basically like and I don't even want to
get into the the the the main parts of
it but like it's one of these things
where I understand that people will say
a couple of things like I'll give you an
example man I listen to Candace Owens
and she says a bunch of things I'm like
oh I agree with what you're saying and
still I don't think it was relevant that
George Floyd committed crimes before
somebody murdered him like why are you
who gives a [__] like why are you
bringing this up as a conservative I'm
just like I don't understand why you're
doing this so it's like one of these
things where I agree with that I agree
with that I can get 10 15 things that I
agree with and then you go off the rails
on this one thing where it's like you
are looking for support on White lives
matter which I'm fine with but then
you're using Kanye West as sort of like
to help you with this whole thing when
he openly has a mental disorder that was
one of the things where I had a big
problem with the Kanye thing is like
Kanye's admitting Kanye has a mental
disorder and now we're holding him up to
the light being like this is an example
of what we need to follow and his
viewpoints are valid I'm like wait can
we just back up and use somebody else
besides the dude who who admits to
getting off his medication can we use
somebody else that's the part that I
think is just kind of like irresponsible
you see what I'm saying
yeah I don't know
um
I think
I don't know if I think Kanye is crazy
or not but he's crazy like Kanye is a
frequently yeah but he's also said that
like he's tired of people saying that
he's crazy when he's like gifted like I
don't know I I don't really want to yeah
he also said slavery was a choice you
know I'm not I'm definitely not speaking
about that comment keep me out of that
one yeah yeah uh but I don't know maybe
I'm wrong maybe what I listen to is like
full stuff like I understand what he's
trying to say no I understand what he's
trying to say yeah too but I I also
think he has a cluster B personality
disorder yeah that's the issue and like
the thing is can we use we're using
extreme examples on both sides like AOC
is an extreme extreme example I think
there's liberals who are way more middle
of the road and like understand Concepts
better than her right men should not be
competing in women's sports that's
ridiculous like there's no there's no
counter argument to that and then like
but then you see this like this is an
extreme example can't we be like a
little bit more moderate and have a
conversation because if we can't there's
no conversation to be had well I think
that's the problem with media to to be
honest is that like people just become
so beholden to their audiences
yeah so they have to be extreme and they
can't like talk about Nuance but I think
Kanye is an example of that I mean he
doesn't he says I love Hitler that's not
nuanced that's that's true that's being
a shock I mean I don't think he does
that for his audience he just says
things
that's mental illness yeah I mean I just
I don't really see it but you know okay
that's my opinion yeah okay yeah
um even Alex Jones is like what the [__]
oh anyway that's why
um the other thing I was gonna talk
about uh so I I would love for you and
Rolo to be able to sit down and like I
don't know what the [__] problem is I
kind of understand what do you think the
issue was where you guys would go back
and forth what do you think it came from
back and forth not back and forth I did
not I did not respond what did I respond
you didn't respond anything I said yeah
yeah
um where do you use that comes from and
then I'm gonna tell you what I think it
is
um
this is a
when when we started he was really
helpful to me and my set yes and so he
was helping me with stuff and like he
was giving me advice
um I start to blow up
um and I was trying to get him to like
Mentor me sure and I think like like I
was saying I would pay him for his time
and like because I really I really
looked up to him like honestly I thought
like he was so smart and like I just
really loved his stream yeah
um and then he basically like he
basically
um he went on this like podcast and then
was like oh Pearl I forgot I don't
remember what he said it really hurt my
feelings though to be honest
um like she's oh she's a hack or
something and like and I was like ah I
thought okay you know
um his exact words to me because we had
a conversation about it is that she he
said the same thing he thought you were
hacked but he didn't dislike you it was
just one of these situations let me talk
I'll talk after you finish if you finish
saying what you're saying
um yeah and so then
um
yeah and that
uh I'm like trying to remember I don't
even remember what happened Max but he
would just always tweet about me and I'm
just like why are we why are we tweeting
isn't this a bit of mature like why do
you think he felt that way
um he he calls me an idiot all the time
so yeah there's a little too much what
but what what do you why do you think he
and I immediately got along
well I mean he's been doing this stuff
for like 20 years yeah so I read
probably somewhere between 40 and 60
books a year oh wow there's nothing like
he's the only human I've met in my life
who reads as much on evolutionary
psychology as me and that includes phds
the reason why we got together and why
it works so much even though we disagree
on certain things like he's he's like I
would never vote for a female politician
I'm like no the lady who runs Las Vegas
is pretty awesome she was trying to get
us back to work during the pandemic she
did a [__] awesome job there's some
exceptions okay
or in in his case where he talks about
like men and women could be friends that
was a big debating point for when we
first when we first met right yeah but
because we kept this thing
evidence-based he and I got along really
well God famously and the other thing is
when I presented evidence to him like I
took him to my birthday party and there
were 50 girls there and they were all
just like we love Michael and then like
he saw the girls I was dating and all
this kind of stuff he was like oh okay I
see this now okay now I didn't see it
this way now I see this and he was open
to this idea that's why it worked the
thing is and this is what I asked him I
was like hey if Pearl red you know
anybody wants to take notes on these if
Pearl red
the ape that understood the universe by
Steven Stuart Williams and pearl red the
evolution of Desire by David Buss and
pearl red why women have sex by David
bust and Sydney Mason and pearl red
um when men behave badly by David Buss
and pearl red mate by Joffrey Wilson and
Paul red
um any of the books by Stephen Pinker or
Gad sad and pearl red why beautiful
people have more daughters by Satoshi
kanazawa do you think Zen you would
still think she's a hacking he's like no
it's like at that point she would have
done the work that's a that's an extreme
microcosm but she would have done the
work in order to have a conversation on
what that's what he that's what Rolo and
I don't want to put words in his mouth
and Rolo disagrees with me he can he can
tweet and say something do super chat or
say something we'll read it
but for Rolo what he respects is that
people follow the evidence
when you had Nick Fuentes on and got you
know yelled at because of you know
whatever semi-cancel whatever all the
controversy and then you said you didn't
know who he was Pearl do you understand
I did 30 hours of study before you came
on here today right I can't I I don't I
only have 50 000 Subs I have to do tons
of work before someone comes on and it
felt like in your situation you were
talking about a lot of these things from
anecdotal stuff I love when you start
talking about 40 of women have had two
abortions that's you quoting statistics
that's great but like for for him in his
standpoint what he admires I'll tell you
right now is the work the study that's
going I'll give you those six books I
compared until you read those oh last
one's alphagot by Hector Garcia if you
read those books I promise you he'd be
like okay now she's taking these ideas
from this the concept of evolutionary
studies as a pro as opposed to you
understand when you just start saying
things based on how you feel how are you
any different from the view or [__]
Dr Phil the the reason why we have no
respect for those people as content
creators is because they're just spewing
either a political woke rhetoric or
they're just talking about their [__]
feelings and for the reason why he
respects Myron for instance is because
Myron reads a ton you see what I'm
saying that's what I'm not saying you're
right or wrong I'm just telling you
that's what the way he would express it
maybe he didn't do a good enough job
expressing it and I'm not blaming you
I'm just saying because I want to see
the two of you work together to be
honest with you but that's what I would
say I don't know if you think that's
fair
um
yeah okay
that makes sense
because I support I think the stuff you
do is great that's just where I'm coming
from
um yeah I just
yeah um I mean I think that he could
have said that to me instead of going
online and I just think it's kind of
immature and I I think it's really
unprofessional to every time you have an
issue with someone tweet about it
um instead of like that was a
conversation that could have maybe been
had behind the scenes right
um
and so here's the thing he I talked to
him about it yeah and I was like I think
you should work with her and then he
said you guys were talking on the phone
and then you did a live stream and then
he felt that Nick Fuentes just showing
up on the [__] stream that he was on
was a little unprofessional do you
understand yeah and then and then I look
for it and you would pull that stream
down well yeah because I I did it
because he was like I thought he was mad
so that's why I pulled it because like
for him like yeah so like I was like oh
[__] I think I think he thinks that you
pulled it because Nick Fuentes said
crazy [__] yeah no that's the first time
I've heard no no I did it because for
like because I thought Rolo was mad yeah
I thought he was mad it was Matt and I
was like oh [__] like I didn't mean to
mean okay but he doesn't like believe me
so like okay yeah my whole thing is that
now look at it from Two standpoints and
the first standpoint
you you from his standpoint you said
you're an Entertainer that's why I don't
hold this against you you're saying
you're an Entertainer from his
standpoint he felt like you didn't do
the work again roll off I'm saying stuff
you don't agree with please like like
chime in
he felt like you didn't do the work I
just gave you seven eight books to read
okay
and additionally when you have Nick
Fuentes on the first time and people are
offended you say you didn't know that
this was going to happen you didn't do
enough research like I said well I'm
having Patrick by David on in August I
will do I'm not kidding 50 hours on him
I will spend two three weeks just
studying up to he was in the 101st
Airborne I have nothing but respect for
than that
and so I didn't say I didn't know who he
was I said I didn't like know all of
what he did and so like sometimes like I
feel like and sometimes and I and I
think this is fair I can do that on my
own Channel that I built wait wait so I
have like the right to bring someone on
and if I don't want like because I think
that sometimes like you go into an
interview you already know everything
about the person like I think what I
really like I'm bringing on YouTube is
having a conversation like that you
would have behind the scenes that's like
in good faith yeah and I feel like when
when you bring on someone that's like
canceled if you know every like bad
thing they've said ever whatever like I
just wanted like to go in with like an
open mind and that's what I was talking
about and I just think it's like okay if
you don't like it then do something else
on your your show for sure yeah I think
it's a valid Viewpoint I'm just trying
to explain to you what maybe where he's
coming from and obviously yeah I wish he
was having this conversation with you
yeah but that's where it happened so but
the thing is it's the first time with
Nick and then it happens again when he's
on the show that all of a sudden Nick
shows up I'm by the way I'm not trying
to do a doctor I want you two to work
together no well I mean with with Rolo I
mean I told him that I was going to
invite content creators on yeah and like
that's and so I thought it was fine yeah
and and then yeah and then he's he's
super like and I was like oh [__] like
the only reason I pulled the stream was
because like because of like because
um some someone messaged me during the
stream and was like that this isn't good
or whatever yeah and I was just like oh
oh [__] and so that was why I pulled for
sure I understand yeah yeah it's just
but again it's like it's kind of like
why are we having this conversation on a
live like now you know when we we could
have had this like yeah yeah yeah listen
I'm I'm trying to be yeah Jimmy Carter
here yeah trying to bring the people
together so I mean I've always been a
fan of Rolo and I just feel like no
matter like it's very immature to always
go to Twitter and always like posting
every time you have an issue and a lot
of this stuff like I think it kind of
makes the space look bad as a whole to
be honest when you're like doing this
yeah we also I wanted you you probably
figure this out we have very different
personalities yeah if you had done that
to me I would be like [__] yes I would
have been excited and that's why I told
role I was like I would I want have me
on some time surprise and [__] have
three of my exes and [__] you know
some more criminals yeah I'm gonna
because I'm different I'm just I'm just
different like that but I think in his
his standpoint with Rolo it's not just a
question of his
um like the number of followers he has
yeah there's a level of credibility he
has because of the books and so whenever
he goes on someone's show he feels he's
lending that credibility to that person
does that make sense so he lends in his
mind he lends The credibility again roll
if I'm saying something you disagree
with let me know yeah he's lending that
credibility to you and then you turn
around and it's Nick Fuentes you see
what I'm saying and Rollo no and I
understood why he was mad like I
apologize like immediately yeah like I
was like oh my gosh I'm so sorry like I
pulled the stream because I was I was
just like oh God like I was like gosh
I'm so stupid like I was literally after
the stream yeah I was on the phone I was
just like I am a freaking idiot pulled
it was done and I but it's like I can't
like when he's constantly thinking I'm
like out to get him or whatever it's
just like it's it's I know you guys like
that you guys had the whole 21 like
whatever like that whole like not maybe
not you but everyone in the manosphere
had that like big beef or whatever where
people were turning on each other but
it's like oh the 21 convention yes uh
yeah and I don't really know what
happened with it but it's like I feel
like I'm getting punished for something
I didn't do yeah and so it's like like
I've genuinely he's called me an idiot
on stream he's caught like he he has
said like things that are so rude when
literally I have only been trying like I
just wanted him to Mentor me yeah and if
he sat me down and said oh read this
book read this book like I probably
would have had like
yeah and so
um like he said something to me about
reading his book religion and then I
read it like so I don't know yeah well
I'm an audiobook person I'm sorry I know
you guys are no no he's already he
actually I think he makes more money
from the audiobooks yeah yeah I think
that's great so
um yeah I didn't even have an issue with
him being like mad about the the second
time I was like okay that was stupid
you're right yeah and yeah but then it's
like he runs to Twitter yeah it's just
like and it's it's like immature like
when it's like I'm the I'm the girl why
I'm not the one tweeting
right sorry that was rude I shouldn't I
should have said that something don't
worry about it I just I wanted you and
again I
I don't know what the whole thing is
we've had a couple of conversations
about this I'm of the opinion I would
like all of us to be able to work
together it's crazy like some of these
beefs but the thing is I don't come from
the red pill Community yeah I come from
that Community yeah see what I'm saying
well I would too I've wanted nothing but
to like work with him yeah like
genuinely
um but it's like I can't
it's like I can only do so much you know
so yeah uh Destiny what do you think
about Destiny
um Destiny's fine yeah yeah
I found him uh I actually was worried
about him like like I said before making
like a bunch of ad hominem attacks I
actually really enjoyed debating yeah no
Destiny's Destiny's all right um I would
actually like for us to find something
we agree on and then debate against
other people I would like to do that
with him because I you know obviously we
don't see the things the same way yeah
it's really interesting because like I'm
not bisexual nobody's touching my
[__] girl like that's not happening
and he finds it that he finds that to be
acceptable and so he loses credibility
with red pill people because of that
whole situation and I think they
shouldn't really attack him for what he
does like it doesn't really matter what
he does in his personal life yeah I
could be honest
um yeah but yeah Destiny's fine yeah
what from what I understood he spent
before we did the debate he didn't
stream for two days and from my
understanding he was preparing because
he was going to go up against Rollo yeah
and Rolo is just like a [__] fountain
or just a just a exactly that was a
great debate yeah that was great
encyclopedia pretend like he even blows
me away bro he comes up with [__] and
like I really try to keep up in this one
Arena I I have a hard time keeping up
with him and this is what this is my
same thing you know what I'm saying and
so that's the thing that's so impressive
I'm just explaining to you that is what
Rolo respects more than anything yeah
the people who'd put in the work
intellectually and that's also why like
he's not as politically conservative as
some of the other people in the space
and that's generally when you when you
just stick to the facts you find that
that tends to be the case it doesn't
make sense
um
all right so let's keep going here with
this um yeah Destiny I thought I thought
was interesting um the other thing I was
I wanted to know was uh the thing I
actually love that you put on was the
worst guest compilations on your uh that
was [__] awesome yeah yeah freaking
Esther yeah that's my least favorite
yeah so what what specifically makes a
bad guest
honestly
I didn't actually put that together when
someone else did but I know Esther's my
least favorite because she kept pulling
she's been on my show three times she
would go on the show and then call me
racist and then go on the show again and
then but I'm like why do you keep if I'm
so horrible like you're coming on yeah
yeah um but she was bad because one if
they over talk you and two if um
they uh what do you call it
you know I think it's like the one lady
when she was like threatening my um my
talent I think that was probably the
worst or they refused to leave I think
that's pretty bad but mostly just over
talking when it's like it's not your
show crazy lady
yeah I'm not actually the best with that
I actually let people get away with like
way more than I should on my show I
think it's actually like my worst it's
interesting I do so many shows but I
think it's like my worst thing as a
content creator is like keeping like a
room calm you know what Rolo does it's
really funny he goes it's a microphone
we can hear you yeah
yeah dude it's pretty funny um yeah I
have an issue with that I so like
Myron's the I think the best traffic cop
there is like he really learns great
yeah he's phenomenal
um and I was like man I think I think
he's like hard on them until I had a
girl who was an astrologer come on here
and just start screaming at me and all I
could think of was like yeah I wish I
was I would just kick this girl off like
I couldn't believe like how incredibly
disrespectful they got and I was just
like man it's yeah it is crazy no and
actually I used to think the same thing
I thought my room was like so mean on
the show I was like he's so totally
until you start doing until you start
doing it because what they do is like if
you give them an inch they'll take a
mile and actually before I left uh I
just had done so many shows I think I
got before I left I was just I was being
way too lenient way too lenient because
it's like if you give them too much it
completely derails the conversation and
you can't keep them on topic and it just
kind of ruins the show
yeah I I noticed that same thing but
I've never been screamed at like that
before I'm like I let you on my [__]
platform yeah this is what you're doing
um yeah there were a couple things I'll
tell you two pieces of hypocrisy that I
love about these variety shows number
one are the girls who talk [__] about
you and then want to come on the show so
that they can get Pub on it right and
they're just they're basically just
trying to use you yeah and number two
are the guys who call girls 304s and
then you ask them the next day hey so do
you remember do you remember Stephanie
from Lamar's you remember Stephanie
Palomar she was on the Wednesday show
yeah of fresh and fit she sent me a
screenshot 1200 new paid subscribers the
next day twelve hundred and ten dollars
a piece that is 12
000 a month that she makes that's over
like a hundred and forty four thousand
dollars a year she made from doing three
hours of fresh and fit getting yelled at
the whole time but you guys called her a
304 and now she's got 140 000 because of
it so there's the you see what I'm
saying
yeah yeah I don't know what they're
doing isn't that crazy though yeah I've
never had a screenshot like that I don't
know no every time I have girls come on
I was like Hey after the show I want you
to tell me like especially when they're
the ones getting attacked I want you to
screenshot before and then after because
here's the thing I don't you want to
call them 304s whatever yeah but then
you need to prove you're not a Sim you
see what I'm saying it's like they're
masturbating while calling them 304s
yeah like looking at their of content is
that what I'm saying yeah like I'm
there's two there's two schools of
thought here right one of them is let's
teach these women a lesson right [__]
these three or four I got hurt at some
point let's teach them a lesson this is
the other one I want to get better with
women and richer and in better shape I'm
only interested in this one yeah I have
no interest in this one at all this
doesn't do anything for Access Vegas is
the reason why we started the show I
have no interest in this one only this
one the guys who call those girls names
I get it I understand why they're doing
it but like when you every time you call
them a 304 let's do a push-up can we do
that you have to have some big old
[__] arms if you did that [__] that's
my whole point it's like I'm way more
interested in like what men can do to be
[__] awesome yeah because the
likelihood of you when you say things
like women we need to improve how many
of them really gonna improve
probably you know it's actually
interesting
I've had a couple girls tell me they
lost like a bunch of weight because not
not many not a high percentage like just
being honest like what percent of people
improve let's just say all together but
agree yeah yeah I'm just so much more on
the positive and because of that like I
don't ever think my [__] is ever gonna
go viral or blow up or yeah I don't know
if I'll ever even have a hundred
thousand Subs because I want to make it
about this right and I want to make
about you improving and that's not as
interesting as the [__] Illuminati
it's not as interesting as like these
girls are all like like all hoes you
understand what I'm saying and I I don't
do gotcha [__] I just don't think it's
it's quite as interesting um let's talk
about this because I think it's really
important you talk about women voting
okay yes yes your beliefs about it are
you I don't know if you jokingly think
what's your view on women voting just in
general I'll let you explain it yeah I
don't I don't think we should vote
unless we're in Selective Service okay
and if I had to pick I would give that
[__] up so fast right because you don't
have to join the military well I will
tell you there's a lot of really good
jobs for women in the military yeah I'm
good on them I'm good you wouldn't want
to be like a C-130 pilot no I do not
want to do that no I do not thank you a
veterinarian for the Army well and I
think that like if working Finance
no well I mean I don't think that's like
fair to be honest because it's like what
you're voting for your
commander-in-chief so the men are the
ones that are going to be on the front
line yeah for sure and it actually it
switched my opinion on this because I
couldn't figure out I I heard like women
didn't want to vote and I was like what
why wouldn't we want to vote and
everyone said it was because of the
military but that's not true if you look
at the anti-suffragettes writings
they're talking about it's the beginning
of the breakdown of the family okay and
that's what happened because before it
was like in Metro and it's it's tough
because we're in a society that like is
like so I'm not saying this would work
today but I just think like
you're supposed to be like it's supposed
to be you're supposed to two are
supposed to become one in marriage
you're supposed to have one vote and I
think that was the beginning of like the
breakdown so what you're saying is we're
talking about the 1920s yeah I'm not
saying this would work today
anti-subridges yeah suffragette for
those of you don't know these are the
women who wanted suffrage for women
suffrage meaning the ability to vote
yeah and uh when they do so uh their
their supposition is that if we do this
it's going to break up the family yeah
and then the family does get break up
now I don't know if we can make a
one-to-one correlation between the two
things I think we might have a better
job of doing that with like saying
welfare yeah
I don't think it was the only thing but
I think it was the beginning okay yeah
uh do you think from a legal standpoint
are you agnostic as to whether or not
women should Vote or do you think women
should not be able to vote do you have
like would you say it to an extent of
yeah I just don't really care or let's
actually repeal the 19th Amendment oh
gosh I don't think that's gonna happen I
think it should be like net taxpayers is
probably a more realistic answer yeah
because yeah because it's like I just
think if you like the way our society is
built like families are like marriage is
deteriorating so I guess yeah so net
taxpayers probably make sense going for
it I just don't think it makes sense
like why does somebody that lives on the
system get a say in it like if you're
paying a hundred percent you're a net
negative to the system so why do you
have a wish yes that's that's probably
my opinion um yeah I mean there are just
play devil's advocate here there are
societies throughout history I believe
you have to be part of the military to
vote in Sparta right if we go back that
far yeah men women could not vote in
like say ancient Rome yeah and then
there were certain instances and like
even more recent times where you had to
be a property owner yeah you'd own land
in order to be able to vote right I
could get behind property owner I'm not
I don't have like it's funny I talk
about it but I I just think like we
don't talk about the double standard
that's more of my point which is that
men um are fined like it's either 250 or
300 000 if they're not enlisted in
Selective Service yeah I mean I just
don't think that's fair
yeah got it yeah so that's more of my
point when I say that okay yeah so but
you you're not like pro pro repealing
the 19th Amendment it's just sort of
like agnostic or one of the things like
because
um it's really funny listening to you
talk to Nick Fuentes and he's like yeah
women shouldn't be able to vote and
you're like yeah I kind of agree with
that okay Pearl how are you gonna get
out of this one explain this oh yeah
well I think moving I just don't think
it's realistic and nowadays right like I
don't think it'll actually happen yeah
um so I think net taxpayers is probably
a better
um solution moving forward got it and
then additionally
um uh as far as that's concerned the
majority of Voters now are women and do
you think that that's had an effect
yeah as far as policy is oh yeah because
that's what the guys were saying in the
UK because I couldn't figure out why
these like custody laws wouldn't change
this is actually how it kind of went
full circle for me because I was
researching like the custody laws and I
was like well how can we like switch
these laws these are crazy like this is
insane yeah when I'm like interviewing
these guys they're talking about like
committing I'm like this is crazy why
like this should be such a simple law
yeah like this is so unfair why don't
they change it but all the politicians
have to cater to the women and women are
more susceptible to propaganda so I
actually think that women when we got
the right to vote it was like a way for
them to control like the population
marks they knew they could that in the
20s that was when radio started becoming
more prevalent so it was a way like they
could influence like the nation
basically
um so yeah that's that's you saw you've
also made comments about purchasing
power with women yeah 70 to 80 percent
of consumer buying consumer buying comes
from women so you your belief was that
you see companies catering to that yeah
more often and then I heard you know
Myron actually say something to the
effect of like well that's the reason
like women were more easy to be
manipulated yeah and so that's the
reason well you'll see it before an
election like they'll do some abortion
campaign with some like super extreme
scenario that never happens and now we
have to go to the polls and vote it's
like we're so yeah we just get emotional
okay cool I don't know enough about this
to say anything yeah the first time I
actually heard about it was recently I
wasn't even aware about 70 to 80 percent
of consumer purchasing power to women so
that's an interesting uh interesting
thing you guys are talking about there
um and the other thing is um this is
another thing I thought was really
interesting is you talked about a man
cheating one time
yeah uh and then whether or not a woman
would leave him in like the willingness
of women to stay in a marriage yeah what
are your what are your opinions on that
before Oh I think cheating is wrong I
don't think lying is okay okay so I'm
not people always think that I'm the
exact same problem I am not a big I
don't like liars okay so don't lie wrong
however
um I saw and it's hard to with the
divorce stats because I've been looking
this up but there's so many different
like reasons for like divorce like
you'll look at the top five reasons and
they're different from like because
they're from so so just so people
understand there's a client attorney
privilege yeah in a divorce so the
actual reason is something we don't
actually know the whole time that's the
problem yeah so you can't you can't say
for instance you could say women are
saying well I'm getting divorced because
of cheating when in reality she was the
one cheating it doesn't matter because
you're never gonna know because you
don't have the right to know because of
client attorney well the the things that
I've seen the surveys or whatever it's
it's like either I saw one that was up
to 40 percent of marriages end because
of infidelity okay maybe it's 20
whatever my thing is as women we need to
think about like what are you going to
do if this happens and knowing that
these are these are the stats for the
kids if if your kid grows up in a single
mother home because more likely than not
like you're gonna get custody like
they're more likely to go to prison
they're more likely to be abused by like
the stuff so the world gets worse
because you you leave your husband yes
because statistically the people who end
up going to jail or committing these
crimes come from single parent
households that's what you're saying
yeah yeah and so I just think like we
should the goal always should be to try
to work it out that should just always
be the the default try to work out
cheating and then I looked up um there's
like a study that said like what percent
and I mean it's so hard because cheating
it's like self-reported of course but
what percent are actually serial
cheaters they said like three percent
and like the majority of the time it's
like a one like 85 or 80 of the time
it's a one-time thing so it's like if it
the majority of the time cheating is a
one-time thing and even if they're lying
let's just say it's only half the time
maybe the default should be to try to
work it out and I've also talked to men
that like they don't talk about that you
know men are in sexless marriages and
that's why they cheat yes they don't
talk about you know maybe you made his
life such a living hell like you know if
you're going home and there's all these
hot women trying to sleep with you and
she's making your life a living hell at
home it's like you might be more likely
to do it like we take no accountability
for that position and my my opinion in
life is everything's your own fault okay
everything in life is your own thoughts
yeah yeah and so I just think maybe you
should look at how how you contributed
to the situation and like honestly like
I've been cheated on before and like I
could say I contributed to the situation
and so it's like I I just believe in
accountability like everything is your
fault um would you have worked it out in
your personal situation I did I mean I
left for like other reasons later but
yeah but yeah I did
um and yeah so I I just think that
everything is your fault I think what
the goal should always be to keep
families together yeah
um yeah let me give a good piece of
advice to people everything is not your
fault but you need to treat it like
you're sure fault because nobody else is
coming to [__] save you right that's
what we say in the military it's like
when it's not your fault you're still
the commander you're the one who's going
to get the demerit it doesn't make any
difference if it wasn't your fault that
the if the co-pilot doesn't put the gear
down the pilot is still dead when you
guys crash into the ground even when
it's not your fault it's still your
fault if you guys take that attitude
throughout your whole life even when
that's what the whole book extreme
ownership is by Jocko willick and the
book dichotomy of leadership jockey
Wilkin Leaf Babin that is the best
attitude to have forget about the
conspiracies or what else is going out
there you need to take ownership for the
fact that if you are out of shape and
you are not financially where you want
to be you have to take responsibility
for that it makes no difference the
Illuminati is a [__] cope the
Rothschilds are a cope regardless of if
they're real you've got to do the work
to get where you want to get that's the
whole thing and the funny thing is the
guys who are propagating those those
arguments they're busting their ass
doing streams they're busting their ass
selling merchandise they're literally an
example of what I'm saying so like you
have to take advantage because nobody's
coming to save you nobody's men or women
nobody's coming to save you um can I ask
you about two more people
um Jesse Lee Peterson man he's one of my
favorites oh he's so funny I don't agree
with anything the [__] says and
I can't stop watching him he's
incredible she's so funny oh my God that
man's hilarious yeah I like him he's
cool he's great I mean but when you when
he says there is no such thing as racism
and there wasn't a such thing I believe
that in certain cases it's definitely
overblown but the idea that like all
these black people were hung in the
1950s because of Brotherly Love is just
better than ridiculous yeah I I wasn't I
was not with that
yeah that's crazy I I can't wait to have
them on at first I at first I was like
angry and then after a while I was like
oh okay this is kind of fun like I get
it yeah I mean you can get angry people
just have their opinion like I just
what's the point point of getting angry
you know I think he just uses different
words for things but at some of some of
the time I just feel like he's saying
things yeah the idea of racism has never
existed I think is a little absurd
because his whole thing was do you know
people willing to kill other people just
because of their race and I'm like Jesse
if it's 98 because of the race and two
percent because they were loud at night
that's still [__] racism dude I'm
sorry you still kill someone yeah so
that's the only issue I hope to talk to
him sometime because I just find him so
[__] entertained he's so funny like
the reactions that people get what he
starts saying you know he was asking me
certain questions he's like he's like
what do you say he said should we have
more white babies I'm like
he goes have you forgiven your mother
yet have you forgiven your black mothers
because black mothers are taking us away
from Jesus Christ
at first I was like No And then after a
while it's like he's just the guy who
keeps jacking up half court shots and
they go in you're like okay Jesse just
keep going this is Watch Jesse Cook yeah
yeah I just I just I don't take him
seriously but I actually find him to be
like really entertaining yeah that's
kind of crazy okay I'm not for uh one of
the things I never got to say to sneako
when we were on the the thing is I
disagree with him being new platformed I
had a super problem with that even
though he said things I don't agree with
I don't agree with the movie platform I
I genuinely believe in freedom of speech
of course I'm gonna I'm gonna continue
to bring on people that have been kicked
off I actually want to do a whole panel
with everybody that's been kicked off by
the way I don't I don't want you to
think I have a problem with you bringing
Nick Fuentes on I'm glad you brought
different if Benito Mussolini was still
alive I haven't said right there for
sure of course I don't have an issue
with that the point was the my whole
point before was you know Roe didn't
expect it yeah yeah
um yeah so yeah that makes sense uh one
other is Kevin Samuels oh my gosh I
freaking loved Kevin Samuels I I just
thought he was great I thought the way
he did his show was amazing um I thought
he was so creative and
um yeah I thought he was awesome he was
great yeah one of my good friends CJ
Sparks got to spend an hour with him and
she started he started explaining to her
this concept of like you're still really
attractive but you're in your late 30s
and you're in this place where like you
can get a hot enough man to have sex
with you but not to commit and he called
a pretty person
sorry you said pretty prison so the
concept of like and this is where a lot
of the delusion comes from is like a
woman a woman can get this guy to have
sex with her but not to commit
and she can get this guy to commit but
he doesn't but she's not attracted to
him
and what happens is she starts believing
this is what she can get to commit yeah
because that's what social media has
told her she deserves and then what
happens is as she stays up here and does
not get one guy to commit and after one
or two power forwards and a couple of
Major League Baseball pitchers run
through her then once she gets to this
point she comes to the realization she
can't get this guy to commit the guy who
she tries to get to commit later is like
oh I have to settle for this after 30
guys 40 guys 50 guys I have to wait yeah
the Sarah Sandberg quote like later on
wait because the guy who takes out the
trash is gonna seem sexy well yeah
actually you know I met with him twice
um yeah I met with him he told me to he
told me to break up with my ex-boyfriend
yeah yeah he did
um and then I met with him again about
my channel and he told me that it was
terrible
what do you mean he didn't like your
channel well he liked it well yeah it
was funny one time he told me he's like
you have a multi-million dollar business
on your hand and I was like wow thanks
Kevin and then the next time I saw him
he was like what are you doing with your
channel and yeah what was the specific
oh it was I was too random like and I
was too
um he was just like you don't know
enough about YouTube and like he like
because I didn't even know YouTube was a
search engine yeah he's like how do you
not know this I'm like I don't know
Kevin I'm just out here you know
um but yeah and then he gave me some
tips to improve it and then I did so
that's nice because that was at like I
don't know 15 20 000 Subs so can you
tell me what your Technique is now you
have two clips channels you have your
main channel oh I got more than that
well how many what do you have now you
can't even count I don't know like so
are you are you putting these you have
Affiliates are you people you're paying
like hot what for there's a lot of
people looking at your meteoric rise and
would like to know and even though New
York right I've seen a lot I've seen
wait wait I've seen a lot of people copy
this idea in this face dude I will copy
in two [__] seconds yes you should
you should all right so my question is
my question is you've had this rise in
also in spite of the fact you've been
demonetized on several platforms lost
your Tick Tock what are some of the
things that you've learned what first of
what are those things you're doing my my
system was outsourced immediately okay
so that was my my system was you know
it's crazy everyone's like oh she's
making all this money I was like I paid
people before I paid myself I kept zero
dollars for probably the first like six
months of my channel yeah um yeah so the
first thing I wanted to create a system
where I could just sit down and talk and
I didn't have to do anything yeah so the
first thing I got was a producer I
didn't I don't want it I don't care
about equipment don't want to know it
that much I used to do it all myself to
start to start you have to do it
yourself unless you got money yeah and
it's actually good to know it then you
are not lying yeah it's actually good to
know it so you know what to hire for so
I'm actually glad I started but
um I did get I call him a manager but
he's more of a consultant so um there's
uh he gives me like channel strategy
I've had him for like three years so
this is before I was even big okay but I
wanted someone that knew what they were
doing with YouTube so I just found
someone I gave them a huge cut of my
channel and I was just like let's go so
at that point I was making like no money
off yeah that's not even care
um then after the producer I got
Clippers and Clippers are just people
they do and I I can send me one yes yeah
yeah yeah well yeah and so there's title
thumbnail and um so their whole job is
just to go on stream pull Clips pull
shorts pull whatever you're trying to do
I've seen AI software that can do this
now it's unbelievable I mean you should
send it my way I have not seen it I have
not seen it um and so then
um and then we have a team of editors so
those are just like their their job is
like the reaction or like the street
interviews or wife school so their job
is like like the Clippers they could
they're like less like they're the only
[__] they have to do for editing is like
zooming in or whatever the editors are
like their their job is like full yeah
how many Clippers do you have how many
editors you have
um well remember I I have a network so
it's not just me so what I did was I
signed people and I let them go into my
system so like Auntie Jenny got like 40
000 Subs in like two three months King
Richie's also got 40 000 Subs 50 000 in
a couple months yeah so they like so I
think total we have maybe
I don't know six editors
um at one point we had ten clippers but
we had we had to dial back because they
weren't all making money so that's yeah
that's how I gave some away
um and then
uh
oh gosh I don't know the two producers
because we do shows six nights a week
yeah just between the talents uh so I
think we do do you see any drop off with
that much content that you're putting
out like is there is there a limit to
too much yes yes what's that inflection
point oh gosh I don't know I mean we
were doing I mean I think we had 30
Clips a day at one point so we had at
one point we had ten like eight to ten
minute or eight to twenty minute clips
and 20 shorts a day
um so I think we did kind of over
saturate we definitely over saturated
them we're kind of drawing back now
um I don't know where the but I don't
know where the drop off was but when
you're doing and that was just on the
main Channel yeah so we were doing 10
clips and 20 shorts on the main Channel
a day and then on other channels we also
had like 10 Clips on each one so I think
we maybe had over a hundred pieces of
content a day it's crazy yeah because I
found out this cheat code now everyone's
on to it but I found out you can get
like you know cheaper like like
basically I mean you can you can get
like deals on people that do Clips
because that's their only job right yeah
and so
yeah I I would say the meteoric rise was
a hundred pieces of content a day
Insanity yeah yeah and I just I think I
was the first one kind of like that
because I was just thinking all right I
would this is what I would do I would
add 10 clips and I would keep making
more money and getting more views I was
like let me keep I noticed um an over
saturation though I would say in like
December November where I was like each
clip is like I think so now we're trying
to draw back a little so what would you
say you're doing now how many like six a
day
um on the main Channel I think it's a
bit too hard for viewers to navigate so
I think we're actually gonna maybe just
do like three a day Clips uh but then
just maybe push those stuff somebody had
shorts though I would keep doing I do 20
a day I will not stop on shorts yeah
that's why everyone was saying I bought
Subs it was so offensive I was like the
people are so old I was like I'm so
tired of these old people no offense
like but like I don't understand how
YouTube works I'm like because I came
from Tick Tock and I think shorts are
the future yeah that's just my opinion I
think they're going to find a way to
monetize shorts the same way like like
when I was on Tic Tac people are making
200k a brand deal yeah so whenever
advertisers come to YouTube it is over
they're not really here on the shorts
game but I get 50 to 100 million views a
month like a lot of those are shorts so
I'm like whenever advertisers you know
get a little thing in the corner it's
over with that's crazy yes wow so 20 a
day on shorts yeah that's that's what I
do yes do you have a tick tock now
no I mean I have accounts like that they
run that are just like reposting clips
from the main
um no they banned my fifth account so I
I think I'll I think I'll get another
one probably oh I lost my first one
because I was posting a lot of stuff
like lifestyle stuff yeah bikini
competition stuff like that so the next
one I just did
um
uh I just did podcast stuff I don't do
anything with podcast stuff me on other
podcasts and I clip it and I do that
kind of stuff and
um that one grew way faster than any of
the other ones like like meaning YouTube
and
um Instagram but I I don't trust the
views I'll be honest with you like
because I run ads on all three platforms
and Instagram is 20 times better than
the other two
that's interesting because a lot of
people come up to me and say they saw me
on Instagram almost more than Tick Tock
and it's interesting because I think
Tick Tock is grossly over inflating you
think so I got 38 million impressions
last month yeah
I'm nobody I got 38 million impressions
last month that doesn't make any [__]
sense and like where so like where's the
conversion in my you know what I'm
saying yeah well it's interesting
because we don't really even post on
Instagram like that so then I get people
all the time like I think it's because
they pull my Clips just to let people
know so I run ads on all three platforms
okay on uh Tick Tock it's nothing I'm
gonna get almost no interactions
whatsoever on YouTube I get about 30
return on investment so for every
thousand dollars I spend I make thirteen
hundred dollars from from selling my
program on Instagram it is 26 to one
every thousand dollars I put into
Instagram I get twenty six thousand
dollars back we scale the my cup my
company we were doing fifty thousand a
month we're doing we did last month we
did 540 000 in Revenue yeah a month from
from Instagram ads so that's what I
found like I from this just from my
standpoint as a content creator I feel
like because I I don't make my money
from AdSense I make my money from
selling a coaching program yeah so
that's why it's different that's why I
have a much more Niche audience yeah and
I don't try to do gotcha videos and I
maybe at some point I'm probably gonna
do reaction videos with Spencer Cornelia
he and I are gonna start doing stuff
together oh I like him I like his uh
videos they're good yeah he and I go to
we we go to uh I wish you were in town
every Tuesday all the content creators
in Vegas we all go to town go to dinner
together oh no way that's fun let's talk
about this you discussed maybe moving to
Vegas it's impossible I I like it here
more than I thought I didn't I don't
like the degeneracy okay no so I was
like I don't think I'll like it but
um I like how much space there is lots
of that yeah and I I do actually like
the heat I think my it would burn a lot
but I do I hate cold
um but yeah I'm in November in [__]
London God hot bro it felt like Alaska
it's so it's this biting wet cold yeah
that just gets in your clothes man it's
I I actually hate London I'm actually
mad I ended up there because I because
of the semi-pro stuff you were doing it
was supposed to be a year and then I was
offered a pro contract in the fall okay
so I was actually supposed to move to
like Portugal or Germany or something
and I was ready to go and then the
YouTube stuff like you know and it's
like what are you gonna of course what
are you gonna pick um and so yeah and
then it was honestly like everything I
was just hiring people so fat like so
many people and everything just got so
big so fast and it was there so you just
stayed there correct yeah but my plan is
I am moving um I'd like to keep an
office though in London so I'd like to
keep like um the talents that I signed
there like working yeah yeah whatever so
on behalf of the board of Tourism let me
give you yeah okay of pluses you will
find that people in Los Angeles when
they film their podcast often come to
Vegas to film their podcast they'll film
several episodes and and they'll go back
to Los Angeles Los Angeles it is so cost
prohibitive to park to travel it all the
buildings are old and [__] rotting La
is garbage I won't be in La okay that's
not even on the list in Vegas you'll
notice that everything here is newer
there's not as much traffic there's not
a humidity and the thing is like
companies are moving here like there's
two million about 2.6 million people
that live here in the in the bowl like
in Las Vegas literally means The Meadows
in Spanish and and there's we're
surrounded by mountains
um next door to us is the UFC
headquarters like there's a bunch of
companies Pepsi has a headquarters like
right next door to what this building
where we are right now it's just a
cleaner environment with less traffic
and when you have your like if you want
big guests Elon Musk comes to Vegas
twice a year like it doesn't matter how
big you want to get like Joe Rogan comes
here for fights the biggest guest you
could ever want they're gonna be they're
gonna pay for themselves to come fly
here but they're not necessarily going
to do that in London and often they're
not going to be able to come to where
you are in Los Angeles as far as having
guests on a podcast one of the reasons
why I've been able to punch above my
weight so much and get like bigger
guests than somebody who has 50 000 Subs
is because I'm here that is the main
reason you you when you came here drive
up Park wherever you want no traffic
yeah come right on in podcast Studio
affordable price [__] full bar drinks
everything like that so that's the thing
it's cheap here because we're looking at
Miami too and I'm like it is much
cheaper here Miami is a time like I love
Miami but it's a time and money suck
you're stuck in traffic trying to go
from Midtown to downtown or Midtown to
Brickell and then the other thing is
like just the cost of doing things yeah
you'll notice like Myron for those of
you don't know that's my department
that's where he films that that thing
right same thing with Brian at uh in
Santa Clara or Santa Barbara that's his
apartment where he's filming that [__]
right we have a studio here and like my
production team is going to give me a
live at it right after this yeah these
guys are the best here people who come
here say this is the best podcast Studio
they've ever been to in their life
sticky Paws just because of the
professionalism like we are all like a
like a family here so I will tell you
that that and then the last one there's
no state income tax here
that's nice so you're paying if you make
a million dollars a year you're paying a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars less
than if you live in California yeah the
the cities are looking at
um Vegas
um Nashville Nashville's good Miami
um and I might just live in Chicago but
have like the office somewhere else
because I'm like I don't know if I'd
want the but we'll see I will tell you
as far as getting guests to come in real
life Vegas will be number one over any
city in the United States really Miami
would be number two yes because people
go to Miami once a year everyone like
kind of goes there for something or
anything that's true yeah but everyone
this is the this is the tourism capital
of Earth 44 million people come here
every year people it's like hey yeah I'm
in Vegas do you want to come by the trip
is they'll write the [__] trip off
they'll entertain clients they'll do
content they'll write everything off and
they'll come out here I'm again mayor
Goodman I'm doing this one for you uh
this is the easiest City I've ever seen
a throw a podcast it's just night and
day because everyone comes here to visit
everyone so that's why I would say
that's why I would give you this one
yeah as far as the degeneracy just go
live in Henderson and Summerlin you'll
never see it okay yeah if you go live in
summer someone was this nice
neighborhood full of like churches
that's what I've heard that's what I've
heard actually this wasn't as bad as
when I came here a couple of years ago I
haven't seen they used to have those
like naked girl pictures they would hand
out maybe I just haven't seen it but
they may have gotten rid of that yeah
there's a lot more nudity when I came
here a couple years ago
um like I was like it's actually not as
bad as I remember yeah so I was like
maybe it's growing up yeah the strip is
not Vegas the strip is in the city of
paradise Vegas is north of that it's
like Fremont Street it's actually the
city of Las Vegas we're a bunch of
unincorporated towns like Summerlin
isn't actually City but has a county
commissioner that's it's its mayor and
then everything in this like the city of
North Vegas was just created to put
homeless people there and all the
homeless people in the in the county go
to this one area don't you think it's
just gonna become crowded when people
move here from I think I think this is I
think Austin is already on the
trajectory of like everyone figured out
that place was all awesome to live in I
used to live in Austin for nine years
Nashville is next and then Vegas after
that oh okay I think those three cities
are the ones where like people are
starting to figure out it's cool yeah
and then a bunch of like Elites move to
that City Vegas people are going to
figure out that if you lived in Austin
25 years ago so [__] fun I cannot
express it now Austin has turned into
one giant Starbucks if you look at what
Austin was 20 years ago that's what
Vegas is now if you're a local here you
get treated like a king free shows
dinner like comp dinners everywhere you
go like [__] any nightclub you want
to go it's just incredible living here I
love it I don't know what music you
listen to go see them like live on
Country I'm a country music fan Yeah
country music go watch them at T-Mobile
Arena I'll take my friend owns a box
just walk right up like literally like I
walk from my apartment into T-Mobile
Arena just crazy that's this is the easy
the best way to describe Vegas this is
the easiest City I've ever lived in
easiest easiest to eat easiest to park
easiest to do anything I've ever I've
ever lived in my life how is it for like
like a family
so the only issue that I would say there
is as far as like the private education
system here is not great okay that's the
only thing I've heard the crime again we
for those of you don't know it's a dirty
little secret Oscar Goodman put every
homeless person in the county in [__]
North Vegas have you ever Drive North
Vegas up to like Chico's Bonitas up in
that area you will see what looks like
Skid Row in Los Angeles there's no
homeless people anywhere else and so
because of that crime is not tolerated
in the city because of Tourism tourism
comes before anything else in Las Vegas
and so what you'll see is a lot of times
they'll sweep things under the rug like
nobody commits suicide in a hotel in
Vegas they're taken out to Cobalt and
pronounced dead out on the street
there's some things like that but as far
as like
um as far as like crime and like growing
a family here I know a lot of people who
do it the only thing I would say is
probably private school that's the only
thing I would say oh like you have to
send them to private you don't have to
but the public school system here is not
great but it's not great in Los Angeles
oh I mean I'm I know everyone's got
their thoughts on Catholic school I know
but I actually think it was a great
thing and I actually I thought it was
good for you to go yeah for me and it
wasn't like I I think the Catholic
School they're talking about must have
just been more in the cities or whatever
because we had no teen pregnancy like
none I don't know I I like I I went me
and a friend like one went to public
school one went to Catholic school and
my brother had the same thing literally
our acts like mine was Five Points
higher than her and we started with the
same grades
wow yeah yeah five point that's a lot
Five Points on an act that's that's
pretty very big difference yeah do you
go out at all like now like I'm just
scared like your dating life now you
have to get too personal here but like
do you go to a are you a bar do you want
to go to a country place you want to go
to Stoney's the country bar over here
like what honestly the past year it just
every oh gosh the past year has just
been crazy yeah like you remember I'm
just doing Semi-Pro because I'm just
someone when I start something I have to
finish it like I just I can't quit what
is it like playing semi-pro basketball
and people know who the [__] you are
how's that oh well I mean the girls
didn't really like it to be all it's a
lot of feminine I mean Semi-Pro
volleyball I was this year last the year
before I did basketball this year I just
did volleyball but
um it was crazy like you don't
understand I was and that's why when
when Rolo's like you know oh well why
didn't you do all this research before
I'm like I just drove to a volleyball
game on the other side of the country we
just drove five hours to a game drove
five hours back and now I'm doing a show
because the shows were like at 9 30 at
night so I was always coming from like
volleyball do you know what I mean so
thank God that was over I was so excited
because I'm just someone like like when
I when I start some I have to finish it
it's just who I am as a person I can't
quit mid-season I know I'm just trying
to imagine you doing a stream with a
million people watching and then like
getting a million views and then driving
across the country and playing a game
yeah like you are Far and Away the most
recognized person on the team on either
team yes or in the audience yes yes but
the girls hated my stuff so it was kind
of awkward sometimes because I'd be like
they would all like talk about what I
like talked about on the show or
whatever were they friendly about it or
were they actually being mean like did
they not give you the ball in the post
well again this is for volleyball
um no I mean I was one of the best ones
like on the team if I'm being honest um
towards the end of season I kind of
didn't play the busk so so tired but
yeah um since like I've had more of a
life since season ended but like oh my
gosh the that that like seven eight
month period was just insane like I was
because remember like volleyball I was
like you have three practices a week or
um three three or four practices a week
no no games twice a week practice four
days a week so it's like six days a week
I'm coming oh my gosh it was crazy it
was crazy but it's over thank you God
like I'm done we're done is there any
video I want to see you playing
volleyball yeah there's um I yeah
there's videos
um on I just released a vlog of it and
then I just there's also I reacted
there's footage from college so every I
reacted to I want to see you play
basketball I'm so down we can't even
like do one-on-one 100 when you come
here next time because there's two
basketball courts in my my uh building
oh yeah I'm so down I'm so down okay I
used to be I used to beat my
ex-boyfriend at basketball I forgot you
have to let him win you know I'm just
gonna beat me like I'm probably gonna
lose my I'm probably gonna lose my
channel I'm gonna be playing hard as a
[__] very competitive I'm trying
to dunk on Pearl don't even take don't
get a twisted it's like oh [__] I'm a
feminine woman
we're gonna break the [__] internet
we do that all right so here's the thing
I want to tell you what I believe is
probably the single worst piece of
advice I see women giving other women
okay
it is when a woman gets ghosted and her
friends tell her no girl he ghosted you
because he was intimidated listen that
word intimidated by your height
intimidated by your opinions intimidated
by the money you make intimidated by
your personality and my my response to
that is I don't like pickles on my
[__] hamburger that doesn't mean I'm
intimidated by them I don't like pickles
I don't sleep on a bed of rocks I bought
a comfortable bed because I don't
because I like a comfortable bed does
not I mean I'm intimidated by rocks I
have a preference for a comfortable bed
and so I hear women consistently saying
this concept of intimidated when no men
have a preference for your nature that
makes it you not attractive to them you
talk about this oh yeah I think that's I
think that's stupid like I don't know
why I feel like these women aren't their
friends that's so your friend your
friend is telling you this hey girl if
you're if your home girl comes up to you
and say like you might want to lose some
weight that's your home that's your
friend I am sorry ladies the girl guys
do not care and this is someone like
I've always like been into Hobbies or
like had stuff going on guys just don't
care and if anything like it can be a
negative if you're too bit like to be
honest like yeah guys really don't give
a [__] about your your work like they
don't they don't care they're
intimidated because you have an opinion
no they're not intimidated it's just
like oh no they'd rather you just kept
it to yourself you know but it's like or
or just keep the peace yeah keep the
peace you know what I'm saying and like
that's the issue it's like I want peace
because you're saying things to me again
we'll go back to the whole thing like I
don't believe in astrology and now
you're yelling at me because of the [__]
like has that happened yeah I was like
no I'm not intimidated because you
believe in astrology you're just wrong
yeah you know what I'm saying like it's
just really upsetting but it's not
upsetting that the girl believes it it's
the setting that these groups of girls
get together and start telling each
other this [__] cope nonsense that
these men are intimidated no he didn't
ghost you because he's intimidated he
ghosted you because you did not give he
was not attracted to the qualities you
showed not enough femininity not enough
loyalty and you know an argumentative
nature like again I have some some
boundaries I know you have wife school
or whatever I have some boundaries a
woman can ask me how I feel she can
never tell me how I feel that is the
quickest way for me to end a
relationship another thing is I cannot
[__] stand or not exercising
exaggerations you always do this you do
this every time like bro what are we
talking about like I can't even have a
conversation when that happens like
things like that do not bring peace to a
relationship if you can just avoid doing
those things then it makes things way
easier yeah it's not I have a preference
for peace that doesn't not mean I'm
intimidated does that make sense yeah
that's the whole thing and like it just
drives and like I'm not mad because
you're wrong because you are wrong if
you believe that what I'm upset is like
women are actually giving this advice to
other women to try to pick up their ego
and you're just hurting your friends
yeah that's the thing like a lot of
times women are nice but they're not
kind yeah and it's not kind to tell
someone what they want to hear if it
hurts them in the long run yeah
yeah for sure it is not con again
short-term consequences versus long-term
Concepts that's why I think I think men
aren't as quote unquote nice but they're
more kind than women like or women were
like quote unquote nicer but we're not
as kind yeah because the telling the
truth yeah got it yeah how do you do how
do you do the recruiting for your show
oh
um recruiting
that was hell that was hell on Earth um
we basically does it get progressively
easier over time
yeah yeah
um blessing built like a website that
the recruiters can log like the guests
but yeah so there's like a whole website
we made that like basically
um and yeah we just pay recruiters per
guest that's crazy yeah all the girls
that come on the show we have like 11 on
every time they're all girls I know and
they're different girls every time oh
yeah I did it early on but again I
outsourced everything like right away
that sounds really smart yeah so I I
think the last time I recruited was
maybe July but of last year but if
there's a special panel I'll pick the
people so like the tape panel I picked
who I wanted on so if there's like a
special thing it's really good yeah like
in the future I want to do
um certain topics like with the people
that we talk about so like I want to do
a panel um with fat chicks talking about
body positivity maybe trainers or
something yeah yeah so I think that'll
be cool you know again remember the
topic we said about personal self-worth
and then like sexual market value yeah
it's not men's fault they don't find
your attract for being overweight that's
not their fault they're not victimizing
you like that's the issue and like that
that's the problem you can have personal
self-worth an overweight woman could
cure cancer that's different than men
finding you attractive yeah the problem
the confusion is again men their
personal self-worth and their value are
the same or similar they're they're
they're near concentric circles they're
overlapping circles but for women their
sexual market value and their personal
self-worth are different the problem is
like when you you hear snico talk about
this before it's like women calling
themselves a tent I'm as a man you know
how much money I'm worth it says it in
my bank account I don't get to make up a
number yeah you know what I'm saying I
don't get to make a how how much do
women like me they like I can look and
see how many women want to date me it's
an objective measurement that I can look
at I can't make up a [__] number
because it makes me feel good you can be
the origin of your own self-esteem you
cannot be the origin of your status you
cannot be the origin of your own value
you can't make up your own value you
have like your value is determined by
other people and and when you express
that to these women they get so angry
and I'm like no no you're still you're
still look God still loves you that's
not what the discussion we're having
we're having a discussion about whether
or not men find you attractive well I'm
not doing this for men I'm like no
you're on a show where you're talking
about your sexual market value you
literally are doing this for men yeah
you know how I lost 30 pounds because
you know when I when I finish Sports you
know my whole life I I worked out
probably three to five hours a day
because
um and I never was the best eater but I
worked out three to five hours a day you
know what I mean and I played basketball
and I played volleyball so after I
graduated college I mean I went to
selling copiers I blew up like a balloon
yeah I blew up I just got fat gay and
like a ton of weight like really fast
and you know what made me lose the
weight the guys were joking around at
the office they were like I would never
date a girl over 200 pounds and I was
like
you know for those of you don't know
she's five eleven and a half right yeah
yeah yeah okay well I can't tell because
we're sitting next yeah yeah well and so
but I didn't look like I was over 200
pounds but I hurt my feelings so much at
the time yeah I lost a bunch of weight
yeah I ran a marathon to lose it and
that's the thing like you could either
take the criticism and say you know what
I gotta make some and I needed to right
even even at my height you shouldn't be
over 200 pounds so you shouldn't be yeah
and so
um yeah that's that's that's my thing is
like if the girls just like took the
criticism and like used it to motivate
them they should get on the treadmill
you did lead by example yeah you know I
ran a marathon do you have any opinions
when it comes to testosterone levels
I've heard you vaguely talk about
something like this this is something we
talk about a lot on the show nothing
strong I've heard I there's a couple
things I talked to I'm a hormone doctor
and he was talking about how a lot of
times trans people
um they actually their hormones are
messed up and that's why they think
they're the opposite gender So like
um testosterone their testosterone
levels like are either too high or too
like vice versa and he would fix their
hormone levels and they actually
wouldn't think they were trans anymore
interesting um I've heard testosterones
lowering the pat like that I've heard
that's like bad for men so a possible
hypothesis will go back to the science
yeah because that is we get further away
from the survival scenario yeah
ancestors lived in yeah your ancestors
so too much testosterone causes
blockages in the artery it causes your
blood to turn into syrup it becomes it
increases viscosity in the blood which
is something you can handle when you're
19 but not when you're when you're 59.
it's it's bad to have testosterone
levels a total test level in the 1100s
when you're 59 years old but if you did
it when you were 19 your body the
elasticity of your vascular system can
handle it does that make sense so what
happens is over time there's an
evolutionary adaptation for your
testosterone levels to lower for a
couple reasons number one evolutionarily
you're just not the the Young Buck
[__] all the hot girls anymore so
you're sort of like stepping back and
becoming the Elder did that make sense
yeah and number two having that high
level of testosterone with degenerative
joints like a guy who's 65 years old who
has all this muscle mass to weigh 275
he's not going to have the joint
capacity to handle it so the adaptation
is for your testosterone levels to lower
the thing is they stay higher the longer
your baling hay hunting the deer doing
this or fighting for your life those are
those survival scenario situations cause
a necessity for your body to produce
more testosterone by the way it's not
it's partially genetic but not
completely genetic there's some studies
that show when men Gamble and there's
beautiful women around their
testosterone serum levels actually
increase when men drive fast cars this
is actually a study done by University
of Nevada Las Vegas UNLV just down the
street uh when men drive fast cars their
testosterone levels go up so one
hypothesis the one I subscribe to is the
idea that as we have gone further and
further away from the survival scenario
instead of worrying about killing the
apex predator that's outside the village
we worry about whether or not it's a
good thing that Elon muskbot Twitter
which like the very fact that we are
even having the discussion like I'm not
saying trans women in sports the fact
that we're even having the discussion
about bathrooms shows that what I have a
roof over my head right three Square
meals I'm fairly certain I will bet not
be murdered as I walk to my car as I eat
food in a restaurant No One's Gonna
Steal My food because they're bigger and
stronger than me I'm away from the
survival scenario as I get further and
further away my body comes with
recognition you need less testosterone
does that make sense that's just the
theory that's the kind of the theory if
you have people that lived in a
consistent survival scenario their body
is going to produce more testosterone
and over the course of years generations
of 11 700 years since the beginning of
the Agricultural Revolution you're going
to start seeing lower and lower and
lower testosterone levels as we start
putting microchips in our [__] head
as we start like uploading our
Consciousness into the into AI as we do
those things it's less I don't need to
punch things lift things right does that
make sense yeah and as I need to do
those things or fight is I need to do
those things less I don't need
testosterone causes thicker joints and
causes larger muscle mass and the
Reconstruction of muscles when they tear
down you can build them up quicker yeah
and so because we don't need that as
much because we're because instead of
Arnold Schwarzenegger now we have
Machine Gun Kelly that's the reason why
you're starting to see my theory of why
you're seeing lower and lower
testosterone levels when you consider
what a person had to do in the 1950s to
to survive including that generation
that went to World War II
and then you look at what somebody in
2023 needs to do to survive which is
[__] nothing then that's the reason
why you'd find that case but if you were
to check the average testosterone levels
of like division one college football
players I bet you'd find it's about the
same as it was 20 30 years ago because
that segment of the population is closer
to the survival scenario they're closer
to I'm gonna get hit or I'm gonna die
does that make sense if you were to look
at Navy Seals this might be a bad
example because I've heard seals
actually take steroids but the uh if you
were to look at some of these guys these
front line operators maricon Marines and
you were to look at their testosterone
levels I bet you're going to find it's
about the same as it's been for the last
30 40 years but the majority of the
population you're probably right yeah
yup all right so here's the last one I
want to ask you about this because I'm
having Roots line on in two days
going to come here on Saturday
um feminism has taken over the church
and your belief about like men taking
these born-again virgins and how the
church is like more prescribed towards
women oh because they always argue the
female point of view it's like I can't
even have a conversation with the
Christians recently and it's hard
because I'm a Catholic okay I was you
know 12 years of Catholic school I would
consider myself Catholic I'm not I'm not
a die-hard right but you know and it's
unfortunate because when I was having
that conversation I was talking about
earlier with the cheating the
Christian's first response was well they
can divorce like it says in the Bible
they can divorce and I'm like we should
be on the same team yeah we should
believe the family should stay together
but you guys immediately take the
woman's side and you guys never talk
about these women that don't sleep with
their husbands and I've talked to so
many divorce attorneys that tell me this
that I know this is a problem and I
never hear you guys preach about I've
never heard you preach about submission
you guys say you should submit to each
other what the hell does that mean like
genuinely and and this is when a Rolo I
watched his stream on church I had a a a
stream a couple years ago where I was
like Rollo ruined church for me because
once I saw this like because I always
felt like there was something like weird
about church and I couldn't put my like
I couldn't describe like what and it
really bothered me right because like
you know I think I think religion's
great like I believe in God I pray you
know but
there was just something weird about it
and I seriously I couldn't figure out
what but I would go I remember sitting
in Catholic school and they would have
these Chastity speakers come in and I've
always been me like I've always had
strong opinions about whatever just like
I'm just the person that gives their
opinion and they would have these
Chastity speakers and it would always be
the same thing like the the guy with the
ran through chick and they would come
and so they can't tell me they don't
preach this because y'all literally and
these were Christians too they weren't
even Catholic well this there some of
them were Christians that came so you
guys cannot say oh we don't preach this
no no I was in high school you guys
literally preached this to me so I will
not none of this and they'll talk about
these girls will come in and say oh I
did all this stuff whatever and now like
I found this husband I found God and I'm
like well this only worked because she
was hot one of the girls that came was
literally an ax America's Next Top Model
that is not going to work for your
average chick all right this works for
the hot chick and what the real message
should be is hey you have this this has
been waiting for you if you make these
choices but if you [__] around too much
there ain't [__] at the end of this
tunnel I think that's a little bit more
on unless you're really hot you'll
probably get away with it hot people
just have privilege like life is life
you know and and so that's what it's
just like not honest and I can't even
have and the the Christian guys will
clip me and like they'll um like there's
this one guy that said in the title that
I I rejected Christianity or something
and I'm like isn't that lying like you
got like and I'm like you're not having
this conversation in good faith if
that's what you're putting in your
entire Christian Channel and they're
literally lying about you yes in the
title that's not what I said I said like
this is something I disagree with in the
church and I don't I don't remember word
for word what the title is so what
they'll do is they'll say oh it was
something like that and so I was just
like how are we supposed to have a
conversation in good faith and my issue
with the like Christianity is I'm like
they preach like two women and they
never talk about the men's issues though
there's a there's a corn and and I I
don't remember someone told me this so
this wasn't me but there's like a corn
addiction group but there's no social
media addiction group and there's all
these women that lead the relationships
and then I see pastors coming on and
saying oh well if your husband's not
leading you to God then how are you
supposed to follow him and I'm like your
submission is not supposed to be
dependent on your husband's Behavior
just like his provisioning or whatever
isn't supposed to be dependent on on
your behavior like you can't and and so
that's what I was realized I'm like
they're all just like there's a lot of
simps in the church that just lie to us
and it pisses me off because you're
telling us like you're selling women
this dream that's not true and then I'll
see these like I was in church right I
was in this Christian church for a while
and I would see like this 25 year old
chick who is a virgin She's Fit she's
feminine I'm like why is she not like
married this is the ideal right and I'm
thinking like there's no men in the
church there's like they're all like I
know and the stats will say it's 50 50
50 but if you look under a certain age
and the singles groups like there were
singles like Ministry like setting
people up in this church and it was like
90 women that were signing up to this
and they also don't talk about how the
women are worse in the church why are
guys saying that why are guys saying
that it's a red flag if if there's God
first in your dating app why even and
I'm Catholic all right but like why do
we have such a bad reputation why do and
the churches will will come in and it
irritates me because they're not honest
like you're coming in and you're saying
oh well it's just the churches you go
not all churches are like that but
you're not addressing the actual problem
and that's what you're it just you're I
just find it annoying it's like and so
I'm not trying to take away from church
of course I think church is a great
thing I think marriage is a great thing
but
how can we how can we fix it if we can't
even identify it's a problem and you're
selling women this bill of goods that at
28 that any guy that she's going to be
attracted to is going to wait I'm sorry
it's just you that ship sailed at 22
when or what nowadays it's like 15. you
feel like the church is having a part to
play in this idea of having women who
had a lascivious past and now they're
coming back to the church but here's the
thing because you came back to us in
repayment for you coming back to us
we're going we've got a myriad of simps
that you can choose from and then you
can end up marrying one of these dudes
yes and the women and the church is
telling these men specifically to have
so little experience with women that
they go for this idea and then now it
becomes almost like a transaction we are
getting women back from only fans and
then we're giving them to these simp men
who have no experience with women and
then the two of them are accepting this
or this Arrangement which will
inevitably end in divorce because these
women are not going to want these men
and they lead the relate like I see it
like women the women lead the
relationships yes and like they Don't
Preach like about like I could not when
I saw this clip and maybe there was more
context of this preacher saying your
submission to your husband like is like
what if he's not leading you to God and
I'm like well how would she know like
she's supposed to follow his lead and
where is the question like why would you
pick someone that's not leading you to
God and plus it's like women we change
our minds every God damn day sorry gosh
damn day and um like so you don't even
know and so maybe one day you think he's
leading you to God one day you think
he's not like that's not supposed to be
the choice the choice is hey you married
him you follow his lead and you pray
like my my
um
like you know I know people in my family
that didn't leave their husbands for
like adultery because they believed he
would go to hell if they left him that
was the level of like of of belief they
had to work it out well yeah well and
faith and that's the thing like where
they really believed what they said and
that's why like I think the men go to
church and they're just like well the
quality of women here is worse the
pastor's gaslighting me because he's
telling me the quality of women isn't
worse and yeah so I'm not and I I I'd
like to say I like church I'm for church
church good religion it's all good yes
but how are we supposed to have good
faith conversations if these guys are
pandering to women constantly yeah
that's was that was a really interesting
topic that I heard you talk about I I
was because I hadn't thought about it
like that but I have seen something
similar where it's like one of the
problems is
um what's very controversial in red pill
is this idea that men should have some
experience with women and the church
does not encourage that and when that
happens you end up in a situation like
with Stephen Crowder I think Stephen
Crowder is a great content creator I
think Steve Crowder has some really
interesting ideas but Stephen Crowder
does not know more about women than me
and I know he doesn't know more about
women than me because he didn't get a
[__] prenup in the state of Texas so
whatever he wants to say about how this
was the first person he was with and he
married her and God forbid if this
happens to Ben Shapiro because if it
happens they're gonna the world is going
to come down on it because he told all
of us you need to marry the first woman
that you you need to marry the first
woman that you sleep with and by the way
there's nothing wrong with him saying
that that's totally fine the problem is
when you tell the rest of us who
actually wanted experience with women to
to uh that we were wrong for what we're
doing we're not making those same
mistakes and we are better at picking up
those red flags that the church you're
saying that the churches
well and the issue
issue to react like the men sleeping
with a bunch of women I I think it's a
reaction to the way women are because
they don't want to get bamboozled how
are they how are you supposed to know
because let's be honest like women will
like what what's the girl's body the
girls are gonna lie for days so how is a
guy supposed to know if she's like an
actual genuine girl or like a girl
that's like been ran through and is just
like Po you know the born-again stuff
without having experience with women and
it's not like like so I was thinking
about it I'm like the women don't want
to get married young
so like because the guys want to marry
the women young it's so great that
you're bringing up the idea of men
having uh you know adult content
addiction yeah they have
uh help for that
seminars for that but women having an
addiction to social media which causes
them social media causes women to not
want to be in monogamous relationships
in the early 20s
oh my gosh this one thing was rich one
of the guys that reacted to me I was
saying like Okay you could argue like
they'll demonize the men for cheating
okay or sleeping around because like we
if you believe and you you have to have
this premise like that attention is to
women as sex is to men so that has to be
the if you don't believe that then this
this doesn't make sure of course okay
but so
the women will have open social media
accounts that are that are the Preachers
Wives or whatever and maybe they don't
have revealing stuff but the point is
Instagram is still the number one dating
app and they're putting their their face
on there which is their beauty right and
you could argue and I'm not I'm not
saying they shouldn't have this okay but
this is just the the equivalent but we
don't demonize the women for having an
open social media account where anybody
can message them but they'll be the
first to demonize the men for sleeping
with the secretary after their wife
hasn't slept with them in two years like
he's the evil person and then they'll
say things like I would never work with
somebody who cheated or whatever this
person just doesn't have morals and I'm
like do you understand I'm condescending
this sounds like do you understand how
like do you like to me I'm like how can
we have a normal good faith conversation
if you're already demonizing the guy and
just saying he's like so horrible but
the woman can do no wrong yeah and so
that's that's my my thing is we demonize
one but we don't demonize eyes the other
and my point was more about the double
standards versus cheating but I really
didn't want cheating to be the hill I
died on I'm really not like for these
you know open one-sided relationships
no well I wouldn't say it's is that when
they're both no polyamories when they're
both polygyny you're right yeah yeah I'm
not I'm really not for them like I don't
that I don't think that's like conducive
for a family for your dad's screwing the
whole time you know that's my opinion
but I somehow got accidentally made
cheating the hill I was like dying on I
didn't mean it to be it happened to me
and uh Justin Waller night so the
concept of so there's a book called the
intelligence Paradox by Satoshi kanazawa
and he talks about as you go up the
intelligence strata you find that men
are more likely to cheat they're also
more likely to stay up later and they're
also more likely to have Messier
apartments or Messier houses as you go
up the intelligence scale
um so one of the things that I thought
was interesting is that when we say this
concept which is true it is true when
women cheat in a relationship you are
far more close to the end than when a
man cheats when a man cheats it is
something that's repairable when a woman
cheats often it isn't again where do I
come up with these ideas it's not
because I'm a it's not because I'm a
misogynist man who believes who's trying
to control women it's because the
studies show that when women cheat 78 of
the time they record they report lower
satisfaction in the marriage men report
the same satisfaction in marriage when
they cheat when women cheat 83 percent
of the time they fall in love with their
Fair partner for men it's like 29 of the
time this would show that when women
cheat they are looking to move to a new
partner that is the end of the
relationship when men cheat that is not
the case that is not saying that it's
okay for men to cheat when I bring up
those stats people act like those stats
are there to excuse men's cheating no
cheating is wrong because cheating is
lying and lying to me is not masculine
so that's the reason why I believe in
that so one of the solutions Solutions
if you want to say it is a poligenous
lifestyle where the man and the woman
together go sleep with other women
that's one of the the solutions another
solution would be polyamory in which
case I have an issue with polyamory and
I have some friends that are polyamorous
and they didn't like when I came out
with this this whole statement is that
polyamory does not work as well for men
it works better for women because women
when they get into a polyamorous
relationship have so many more options
than a man does in the example I was
giving one time I was at hedonism the
it's a it's a Resort in Jamaica I was
talking to this guy named Bob I think
he's he has no his name was Rob I was
talking to this guy named Rob and Rob
was like yeah me and my wife were
swingers and we we talked to multiple
people or whatever and his wife had
seven dudes lined up to have sex with
her and I'm watching Bob right here and
he's like lucky to get a make out and
I'm like this bro I don't think you
understand how this works you're paying
for her whole life and she's about to
get ran through by the Jamaican bobsled
team like what are you doing bro so
that's that's the only reason why why I
said that again not prescribing this
these are just different options that
people yeah that people come up with
yeah I'm not I'm not for that but I
somehow I was like I don't know how I am
arguing this hard like about any day
because you're because you're you're
doing a description and when you do a
description that's not interesting so
they want a prescription yeah so they
they imbue a prescription on you yeah
even though you didn't give one yeah
cool do you want to do anything with
super chats I know we've gone for a
while you want to do that you want to do
with hers I don't know if I have any um
I don't have hers pulled up I have all
yours actually okay you wanna do mine
okay absolutely so uh we've got oh okay
that's coming through
um we've got a lot from uh Glenn
Lawrence here okay let me just pop this
up
at the very beginning of the show says
my body count is Mike's max bench press
your body count is 375 pounds it's
[__] insane that's insane not kidding
I'm not 375 I'm probably like 350. I'm
lying I'm lying dude I can't do 375. go
ahead and uh when uh Pearl was talking
about playing basketball he says uh they
can roll Pearl with the five dollar
Super Chat okay and then uh uh later on
we were talking about marriage and
divorce and that kind of thing uh the
problem isn't uh isn't marriage it's the
problem is how we do divorces that's
exactly how he worded that okay yep and
then uh just max with a five dollar uh
Super Chat said uh Mike what's up Pearl
what's the biggest difference between
Chicago and London who were the uh who
were
the correct answer is handguns
favorite guests in your panels and why
the biggest difference I would say is
London's just really crowded
um I mean so is Chicago but like lunch
is just so much more like on top of each
other crowded London is a much better
public transportation system
um the buildings are a lot prettier and
there's a lot more I mean Chicago is
history but it's like a great it's just
not the same
um
um Chicago I don't I've never lived in
downtown Chicago
um so you know take this with a grain of
salt I would say Chicago maybe it's a
bit more Greenery I would say yeah
um what was the second question
uh who are the uh your favorite guests
in your panels and why oh
my favorite guest
um
I mean Tate definitely
I actually forgot
see oh no no I remember I actually
really liked the the thing I did with
CGA because I learned a lot about
divorce laws and that like this was like
a while ago so this was like in
um the fall and I really liked doing
um who else on my show did I really
enjoy oh my gosh Auntie Jenny that's my
favorite panel yeah
I I saw her and I was like that's a
that's a really great yeah she's
terrific and she Jenny yeah so terrific
terrific um anymore yeah let's see
um so uh then we've got waterproof with
a two dollar Super Chat he said uh when
are you doing a meet and greet here in
looks like Orange County California occa
uh for for her or me doesn't say okay so
we just announced we're gonna do a meet
and greet in it not [__] by the way I go
to uh Chicago once a year because I work
for a financial Network that's up there
so if you ever do content up there the
other thing I was going to say is
Chicago actually does have a summer
oh yeah in London they have a summer but
it's not quite let's all go on the boat
in bikinis it's not quite the same
summer there oh yes that's really true
and Chicago gets freaking freezing oh
gosh yeah it's a little different yeah
anything else uh the very last one is
another five dollar Super Chat from
Glenn Lawrence uh this was uh when you
guys were talking about uh uh
accountability stuff yeah everything is
not your fault but you always have a
responsibility to act yeah have you ever
read extreme ownership by Jacob
highly recommend that that's at the top
for ex for self-help top five book of
all time he's a Navy SEAL he's a Seal
Team Six and he basically goes over it's
very similar to if you ever read uh um
uh hustle Harder by 50 Cent hustle
harder goes he talks about business
things in his life and then he he
relates it to when he was a crack dealer
in in the Queens I mean he has like
these Leadership Lessons From it this
dude is the same thing except he was a
Navy SEAL and then he relates it to like
business and it's so good but the main
thing is no one's coming to save you
it's always your fault even when it's
not your fault it's one of the greatest
books I've ever read this is terrific
terrific uh we don't have anything for
Pearl pulled up
um let me see if I can okay cool because
I'm looking at your thing and on my
phone I can't see you definitely had
some but I can't see them yeah I don't
know it's um
scroll down okay awesome while you're
doing that last thing we want lit so I'm
a Matchmaker we want to find Pearl of
dude so what do we do what do we what do
what are pearls requirements and then
what have been the problems previously
for Pearl to find Pearl of dude by the
way just let you know all my friends
meet their Partners through me that's
one of the when I have this many female
friends and this many guys yes
um these big events that I throw they
end up becoming matchmaking my friends
get married like it's it's a very common
thing because I can like it's it's a
good quality type of girl who comes to a
charity event or wants to rescue animals
and then a dude who's like you know of
financial means to make it into you know
a certain type of event so I'm just
curious in your situation what are what
are you looking for what are where are
many men falling short and what are some
issues
well
um I want a guy that wants um a good
amount of kids okay um you want to start
that pretty quickly ideal I mean yeah
ideally
um so I want like four kids okay so I
mean at least at least two but I've
always wanted four okay
um
um I've always wanted a guy
that's not like a super big partier to
be honest like every now and then is
okay but like I forget everything I said
I can't help Pearl at all [__] this all
that I'm scared I don't know anyone
never borrowed out
um I was kidding I mean like I ideally
right
um height close to my it's okay if he's
a bit short so 510 is fine yeah five
Ten's okay um I mean five nines all
right too um I just like five five six
is kind of you know yeah yeah but
um I like guys with like nice Smiles you
know I would I would imagine because of
the success of your channel is money a
big thing for you now
um not really I always said and people
always say I'm capping so you know maybe
yeah but um I mean I made 42k plus
commission at my old sales job yeah and
I feel like social media like it's real
but it's not real do you know what I
mean so I'm not really that judgmental
about like income because I feel like
it's like I'm talking into a microphone
how am I gonna be better than you know
yeah
um so I don't know like 42 roughly is
what it'd be yeah you'd be fine with 42
000 a year for the guy you're dating
yeah I mean it depends how old he is
right you know like you know but if he's
my age yeah do you see any issues with
like as you go further in the
relationship and you start making seven
figures a year and he's making forty two
thousand dollars a year that you are
going to be like the private school
tuition is yours now right yeah do you
see that being an issue at all probably
yeah I mean it's an issue for everyone
else yeah so it seems like that would be
a tough an issue in that it would
emasculate him that's what I'm asking
yeah um no I think that would be tough
yeah yeah I think that's you know okay
in in your last couple years where have
men fall fallen short or where has the
situation fallen short where you can't
find this
so it's kind of like you could
think but I'm I don't want like long
term I just don't see myself in London
like I just really I want to be close to
my family
um before that
oh and the main thing for me really
conservative yeah politically
conservative yeah I would say um it was
hard for a while to find like
conservative guys I meet more now but
like you ready Tristan you ready I'm
like like I like guys that almost don't
think women should vote
like that conservative can we get Jesse
Lee Peterson over there yeah yeah maybe
he's single like if a guy says anything
in the middle I'm like I know you know
go to you and Nick fuentes's wedding
it's interesting you know no nick him he
doesn't I'm not the right type of of
white remember he wants the Italian you
know God damn yes crazy yes the thing is
like he'll say this and then he'll have
this big smile on his face he's like of
course blacks and whites should not
mongrelize
the thing is I do and that's that would
be crazy but I'm not sitting there well
you know
um so so that's that's the issue the
issues that you've had with that one of
the things I would worry about you so
you understand I'm take I'm out on a
[__] limb with the with my girlfriend
like because guys are not taking their
girlfriends on these shows like I am
right yeah and so if all of a sudden she
turns crazy it's gonna reflect poorly on
my whole situation I know I'm taking a
risk and the thing is I you know trust
my girlfriend that's why it's worked out
so far and she's so [__] stunning
that I do want people to see right she's
beautiful I love your girlfriend I'm
like I know I've never met her yeah but
I was just such a fan on whatever I was
like you go yeah so so the thing is um
the public so my relationship has become
a bit public I'm nowhere near as famous
as you guys are the issue for you is
when you date someone
the the scrutiny that your relationship
is going to come under and the scrutiny
that this dude is going to come over if
he does anything wrong yeah I would
prefer no one to even know we're dating
there you go that would be my salute I
would like one day I'll just pop up
married and you guys will be like you
had a boyfriend I'd be like
yeah I I sorry forgot to tell you guys
so it was it was a content creator that
might be a problem right or maybe you
just don't tell them that you're seeing
someone else what do you mean
um you would want to keep the
relationship Under Wraps is that what
you're saying well I mean he'd have to
be like it I I would
if I liked him I'd do what he wanted to
do you know what I mean like he would
have to pick but I mean ideally like I
think it's it's that's a hard position
for a guy to be in yeah especially with
how controversial my stuff is yeah
um you know if I'm fighting whales one
day and you know I get all this like now
my family's getting harassed then he
could potentially get harassed um so
yeah I would say
that my ideal situation would be for
people to not know but if if he felt
like that was a problem then like people
can know do you believe in long-distance
relationships with as much as you're
traveling as you do
um no no I mean that's why I'm coming
back because like I I don't think long
distance really that's right yeah I
don't I don't plan like half the reason
I'm traveling so much is I'm looking at
cities I'm trying to figure out where to
move I'm not planning on doing that when
I get back I'm trying to I'm in the US
baby these people can come to me now I'm
not going
you know I'm trying to I'm trying to
figure out where I just want to move
yeah yeah that's awesome well no I mean
what are that what are the guys like in
Vegas they're incredibly [__] good
looking and that's the problem oh like
the girls here complain all the time
like the dudes here are all like six
three Australian like fitness models and
oh but it's like dangerous because
they're they're screwing up everybody
like oh look I'll be I'll be alone I'll
be um I'll be just lonely things and and
yeah but if you if you move further away
like yeah like I said like Summerlin
you're gonna find different types of
dudes okay the problem I will say the
problem dating here for women is that
there's so many attractive women here
you were we were talking about this
before that it like it it's um what's it
called it's like a Cascade effect if
there's a bunch if you live in a city
with a bunch of strippers yeah and
you're like well my husband was not
going to want to be with a stripper but
you go to the gym and every girl there
who strips at the club is like ripped
with big fake boobs and like yeah then
what happens is it goes down to now the
next level of girl who's like a
receptionist she's now in her mind
competing with the stripper so now she's
going to the gym more and so the the
whole city becomes kind of better in
shape if that makes any sense yeah and
if you go to to Houston or Dallas you'll
notice that there's a difference there
between going to like New Jersey or
Chicago the girls there do because in
the winter they can just cover all this
up right in Texas in the summer you're
just in a bikini all the time every girl
is so I'll be in the best shape of my
life here I think you're gonna not
without without consciously recognizing
it gonna want to get in the best shape
in your life here because when you go
out you're just going to notice that the
locals here the locals here are the best
looking people I've ever seen in my
entire life the locals here prettier
than Miami yeah definitely Purdue really
I was like those are the most beautiful
women
I don't only like Hispanic women like
that's the difference I think Hispanic
women are really attractive I just think
there's more variety here oh I see I
could see that yeah
um so that's that's where I would say
it's a little different now the other
thing is the yeah that's that's what I
would say is the biggest difference the
dudes here are here because of their
physical attractiveness if they're a VIP
host of bartender or whatever and the
service industry is so big here that
like you're just going to notice you're
going to meet guys that are just
ridiculously good looking but yeah
there's gonna be these red flags there
yeah that's that's the only thing I
would say about living here yeah
so don't don't date guys in Vegas you
could you could listen we don't have to
be that reductive you could probably
find a great guy but I will say like
it's crazy to me whenever single guys
don't want to live here like this is
this is just something this place is an
easy mode it really is it really is like
my girlfriend's stunning and she
constantly tells me whenever we go out
she's like oh my God these girls are so
pretty and I'm like I think you're
prettier but like I do understand what
you're saying whereas when we go out
Dallas or Houston it's just not the same
you just don't see the same thing yeah
you know what I'm saying so that that's
probably the biggest difference do we
have any other did you find any super
chats for her yeah yeah so I've got uh
uh three big ones for Pearl okay uh so
we've got uh from Stacy Campbell uh
whale merch I'll have you you snail I
don't really know what that means but
where thank you Stacy yeah and then
we've got uh from a ten dollar Super
Chat from Christian Montague hey Pearl
I'm in the process of getting divorced
interested in being part of your
documentary are you looking for more
participants yeah I have oh gosh I have
such a line for participants
um but the best thing is if you can come
to me in either London or I'm in Chicago
next week so you can DM me on Instagram
um if you have a story that you want but
yeah and uh last one is a five dollar
Super Chat from enter black dragon pearl
I still love and support what you do
hard question to ask but hearing you now
with Nick Fuente uh was Nick Fuentes
really worth the cost of everything you
lost
um what did you lose
um sanity yeah was there anything
tangible you lost
um not really to be I mean are my Subs
right like slowed but I mean I didn't
lose any subs yeah yeah I actually
gained still what would you do different
if anything
um
I probably just would have ignored
everything I probably still would have
had them on to be honest like I believe
like I I just I believe what I believe I
believe in freedom of speech
um I actually really thought that was a
good piece of content I thought I was
one of the few people that interviewed
him without trying to gotcha him without
with just letting him
speak and I you know people can disagree
with that but I I think it's good to
have a platform like that
um the criticism of some of the
African-American I'm sorry African and
yeah anglo-african is I don't know what
you call them in in the UK yeah
um did they were their criticisms
hurtful to you at all
um yeah I mean I would say would you
work with the ones I would say um having
a co-host call me a colonizer was a bit
hurtful I would say having someone that
spent I don't know a week with my entire
team in our studio insinuating that I I
was a racist was hurtful
um and especially after he told me he
did not watch the video which is a bit
like you would think if you're gonna
make a hit piece on your friend you
would watch the video yeah you know do
you know what I like that would be a bit
um but overall um I would say like it
was not like I guess worth the stress in
hindsight but I would still do it again
because of what because I believe like I
believe in freedom of speech yes so I'm
just gonna I'm gonna say my viewpoint if
anyone gives a [__] you're not a racist
because you let another racist speak
if you believe Nick Fuentes is a racist
or not maybe some of you don't maybe
some of you do you're a racist because
you're a racist you're a racist because
you believe that one race is higher than
another yeah also it there's a
difference between racism and Prejudice
there's a difference there we could get
into that whole discussion but you
giving a platform to someone who says
something like I had flat earthers on
here that doesn't make me an
anti-scientist because I was debating
flat earthers and I was we had a nice
cordial conversation I actually would
like to debate them again you're not a
racist because you let a racist speak
people should be allowed to speak that
is the basis there's there are many
amendments but one of them comes first
is the freedom of assembly and freedom
of expression and there's a reason why
when we join the US military we swear to
Serve and Protect the Constitution of
the United States against all enemies
foreign and domestic which is why I
support anyone's right to say whatever
they want I also support people's right
of of age of age if they want to
transition from a man to a woman I
support that as well that's freedom of
expression I don't support you telling
nine-year-olds to [__] do it I have a
[__] problem with that but I don't
but if somebody wants to do it over the
overage fund you do whatever you want I
will support people's right to kneel but
I wouldn't have knelt for the national
anthem because I'm not going to be a
hypocrite I didn't join the US military
to Serve and Protect the Constitution
and then get to choose which one of the
Amendments I support and the ones that I
don't make sense so just my opinion
you're not a you're not you didn't do
anything wrong for platforming the guy
you do some you're a racist because
you're a racist you're not a racist
because you've let somebody else speak
that's all I'm saying yeah okay yeah but
that was a lot of pushback it's crazy I
like broke I broke the manosphere yeah I
was like there was these people fighting
over me like they literally stopped
being friends with each other because of
me I'm like gosh darn this is crazy yeah
all right well Hey listen I want to let
you know I know I kept you for a long
time yeah I want to let you know um you
always have a place if you want to come
on zoom and have if you want to tell
your side of anything you always have a
place even if you say something I
disagree with I mean you're never gonna
I've never have an issue where I'm not
gonna talk to you face to face if
there's ever ever an issue I want to let
you know that because I know I have an
affiliation with Rolo and some of these
other guys who've been critical of you
that's not me okay I just wanna let you
know no matter what if you want to say
something I'm down to talk about it okay
sound good I love your content I think
it's great I think what you're doing is
important I do understand where people
get this criticism the only thing I
would suggest and you don't have to
listen to what I'm saying is that there
are seven books I would highly recommend
that deal with specifically with
evolutionary psychology because from
that standpoint it's not your opinion
anymore you have a basis a scientific
basis for every single one of these
things you believe that that's the only
thing I would say besides that is there
anything else where can people find you
uh you know I do have a channel it's
called just pearly things um
yeah make sure you guys like this video
okay I'm so tired of people watching and
not liking it it's like it's free yeah
so we're putting this out for free they
don't even like the video yeah but yeah
um follow me just pearly things
Instagram just pearly things one
um
not on Tick Tock oh and I'm on I've been
tweeting a lot I've been really big on
Twitter I have been tweeting like a
Madness so follow me pearly things with
a z at the end nice that's nice okay
awesome well I appreciate your support
you didn't have to come out here and I
really appreciate you coming out here
and doing this for this whole time and
if anything you need from me let me know
I would like for you and Rolo to be able
to do a show together if if I got to be
the moderator I'll [__] do it
um yeah I need something in writing that
he's not going to Tweet about me if
things go awry right that's what I need
I need something
that that like takes the Twitter away
okay because I don't I don't I don't
know if he gets mad again I don't want
to see tweets okay but I'll think about
it you know awesome I wish you were here
tomorrow night because we're doing
access Vegas but I know you guys no I'm
leaving I'm leaving well one of these
days I do want you to come on so
hopefully okay you can come in and do
that and then we can take you on stage
at zuk and you can hang out and watch uh
what's Duke I love it it's a nightclub
here okay I imagine you probably don't
go to any you don't do any nightclub
stuff well you see I I can't really
um I have a disorder it's like for
strobe lights really yeah it's called
this yes okay I couldn't even Club if I
wanted to it's called I'm photosensitive
seizure disorder it's different than
dislike or whatever the the that's
different than the one what's it called
yeah it's Dia it's different than
epilepsy because it's only strobe lights
so you know I'm good in day-to-day life
but strobe lights yeah okay tall Beach
on stage we're taking we're taking her
up there and then and then and then I'm
dunking on her yeah all right guys stay
tuned we got much more coming your way
we got many many more interviews but I
really appreciate you guys sticking with
us for this entire time uh thank you
guys for watching please like share and
subscribe I cannot it possibly Express
you how much I appreciate like all the
downloads from all the different um
different uh platforms and the fact that
I have 40 million views on [__] Tick
Tock last month I still don't understand
how that happened but I really
appreciate that you you guys and I will
see you all in a few days I'll see you
guys all next week thank you
foreign